Monkan.
Easy as f**k!
So, da sind wir.
Dieser komische Radiostream kann es nicht entscheiden ob er lauter oder leiser sein soll.
Das suckt.
Was brummt denn hier für ein Lüfter?
Brummt hier ein Lüfter oder ist das draußen?
Ach das ist, ach das ist draußen!
The f**k!
Gentleman Deep Radi-
Ach du Scheiße, die haben Namen immer ey!
Gibt es nicht irgendwie was Gescheites für Hintergrundmusik so?
Irgendwas wo einfach nur gedudelt wird, wo nichts gesungen wird?
Ja, das hört sich schön nach Fahrstuhl an.
Das hört sich schön nach Fahrstuhl an, das ist gut.
Nach, äh, naja vielleicht nicht unbedingt nach Kaufhoffahrstuhl.
Heute mal Face Reveal, das wollt ihr grad nicht.
Das kenn ich.
Ähm, X Shadow Ghosts, das hab ich schon ab und zu malen gehabt.
Das ist aber, das ist dann gar so lahmarschig.
Face Reveal wollt ihr heute garantiert nicht.
Ja.
Ja genau, Conny, bei einer Million Abos, richtig, bei einer Million Abos.
Da steh ich auch zu, das hab ich gesagt, ja.
Eine Million Abos kommt auf Face Reveal, ja, ja, das wird gemacht.
Allerdings sieht das nicht so gut aus mit einer Million Abos.
Soll ich euch mal meine YouTube-Statistiken zeigen, wie die aussehen, wenn ich nichts hochlade?
Passt mal auf.
Da ist nichts mit Abos, ne?
Nix hochlädts. Du siehst das richtig, immer wenn ich was hochlade, gehen die Abos auch hoch.
Also, ja, wenn ich am Stück hochlade, ne?
So, nix hochgeladen, nix hochgeladen, nix hochgeladen, nix hochgeladen, hochgeladen, nix hochgeladen, nix hochgeladen.
Was ist das allweil ich denn?
Ja und so ein Video alle drei Monate oder alle halbe Jahr tut's da halt nicht.
Da musst du wirklich schön konstant, ne?
Hier war ich echt auf nem guten Weg wieder.
Das war Weihnachten rum.
Weihnachten rum 2017 auf 2018.
Da war ich echt auf nem guten Weg wieder, ja.
Die Jahre davor, wo ich mit dem ganzen Call of Duty und Battlefield Zeug viele Views hatte, steht da gar nicht drin.
Da ging's ja bis zwei Millionen hoch.
Naja, da war ich auf nem guten Weg, ne?
Was hab ich gemacht? Aufgehört Videos zu machen.
Wieder nix hochgeladen.
Aus meinem NAS-Projekt, das ist immer noch nicht fertig.
Ich hab mich irgendwie sehr an meinem Heimautomatisierungszeug festgefressen.
Und außerdem fehlt mir so die letzte wirklich überzeugende Hardware-Firma an Eigenbau NAS.
Das hab's euch ja gezeigt.
Ich hatte ja damals diesen Vierkern Celeron gekauft.
Diesen Dual-Core Celeron.
Nee, Pentium Silber, also Atom, nicht Celeron.
Und das Problem ist, dann hab ich festgestellt, hey, zwei Kerne sind zu wenig, wenn man 10G ordentlich füttern will.
Ich mein, 10G kommen eh nicht an, sondern nur 6 oder so.
Mit dem PC-Express-Slot allerdings ist okay.
Das Problem ist, wenn du Verschlüsselung an hast und das Ganze über Samba überträgst, ist zu langsam mit zwei Kernen.
Da brauchst du vier Kerne, dann wird das ganz gut gehen.
Und mit vier Kernen gibt's keine gescheiten Boards.
Da gibt's nur Boards, die maximal...
Warte mal, ich weiß gar nicht, mir irgendwas hat mir an den Boards mit vier Kernen nicht gefallen, was gefehlt hat.
Entweder am SATA-Anschlüsse gefehlt oder PC-Express-Anschluss, eins von beidem.
Am liebsten hätte ich ja für meinen NAS dieses Board hier.
Das hätte ich am liebsten für meinen NAS.
Weil, das hat zweimal SATA, das ist schon mal an sich für NAS natürlich ganz praktisch.
Und, was viel schöner ist...
Man sieht's hier hinten nicht so ganz.
Es hat ein Vierfach-PC-Express-Anliegen, den man quasi rausführen könnte.
Das wäre natürlich für eine 10G-Card optimal.
Normalerweise ist der Slot für eine NVMe SSD gedacht, aber...
Ja, so wirklich... Und selbst da bräuchte ich dann theoretisch noch...
Bräuchte ich dann theoretisch noch für die Platten, je nachdem, noch ein USB oder so.
Und ein anderes Board wäre auch noch ganz gut, ich glaube von MSI ist das.
Mal gucken... Nee, nicht von MSI. Wie gibt's denn da noch? Gigabyte war das, glaube ich.
Und da war das Problem...
Und da war das Problem bei dem NAS...
Also bei dem Board, genau das Board habe ich, das ist eigentlich ziemlich gut gewesen.
Da hast du einen ordentlichen PC-Express-Slot und einen M2-Slot.
Das heißt, du konntest da auch... Du konntest eine 10G-Netzwerkkarte nehmen.
Und du konntest noch über den anderen Slot noch mal PC-Express machen und dir noch mal SATA-Ports holen, wenn du willst.
Das wäre das optimale Board gewesen. Das Problem ist nur, zwei Kerne sind zu langsam für das, was ich machen wollte.
Und das nächste höhere Board, was es von denen eigentlich gibt...
Reichen die zwei SATA-Anschlüsse? Ich habe doch gerade gesagt, wenn man das Board genommen hätte, hätte man noch mehr SATA-Anschlüsse machen können.
Aber ja, zwei SATA-Anschlüsse reichen mir.
Ich habe hier aktuell 3x10TB dran im ZFS-Rate 1, also das ist quasi wie ein Rate 5.
Allerdings ist das viel zu oversized für mich daheim, das braucht eigentlich kein Mensch.
Wo stehen die Dinger denn jetzt hier? Embedded IoT, glaube ich, Mainboard.
So, und jetzt kann man das hier bestimmt filtern.
Genau, und... Moment, nein, nein, nein, das ist verkehrt.
Warum benennen die das Zeug denn immer nicht richtig? Das ist doch grausam.
Und warum kann ich das nicht filtern? Warum kann ich das nicht filtern? Wo ist denn jetzt das Board, das ich vorher hatte?
Ok, bei Sockle, Intel Onboard.
Kann man die jetzt vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter filtern?
Hier, da kann man es filtern, genau.
Genau, und das ist das nächste höhere, das wäre eigentlich ein richtig gutes Board.
Das Problem ist, das haben die irgendwann mal angekündigt und nie released.
Also sprich, das Board, was ich ganz gut eignen würde für das NAS-Build, oder am besten eignen würde für das NAS-Build, gibt es nicht.
Das haben die einfach auf ihrer Homepage stehen, als würde es das geben, und haben das auch irgendwann mal angekündigt, aber das gibt es nicht.
Das haben die nie veröffentlicht, und nachdem sie das ja Mitte 2018 gemacht haben oder so, guck hier, bla, blub, wird das auch nie wieder rauskommen.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich entweder jetzt mir so eine Lite-Variante bau für mein NAS, die einfach ein bisschen, die einfach überbrückt, bis die nächste Generation da rauskommt von den Low-Power-CPU-Dingern.
Ach ja, und zwei SATA für NAS reichen mir persönlich jetzt mittlerweile schon. Ich würde das eh so machen, also wie gesagt, das, was ich aktuell habe, ist komplett aufwassert.
Ich würde es jetzt eh so machen, ich mache einfach noch eine 10TB-Platte dran, und eine weitere 10TB-Platte, die eigentlich permanent aus ist, und einmal nachts drauf geersyncht wird, fertig.
Ja, und dann überlege ich mir noch, ob ich wichtige Sachen offsite-backupe auf Google Drive oder auf irgendwas anderem.
Ich hatte ja mal damit angefangen, allerdings irgendwie habe ich da nicht durchgezogen.
Warum schreibst du manchmal eine 1 in die Adresse? Das müsste man eigentlich mal ein Kommando zu machen. Wir haben Mods da, dann erkläre ich das jetzt mal kurz, da kann man ein Kommando drauf machen.
Also, warum ich ab und zu, und ganz besonders schlimm ist es hier, wenn ich in irgendeinem Editor bin, warum ich manchmal ein 1er und so copy-paste, das liegt daran, weil ich mir das angewöhnt habe.
Nicht, weil das irgendwie einen tieferen Sinn hat. Da sieht man einmal, dass ich 1 copy-paste so, und dann aus-cutte, oder auch, was ich ganz gerne mache, etwas rechts anklicken und dann auf copy und so.
Das ist einfach, einfach tick von mir. Das ist so hier, sowas in der Richtung. Das hat nichts zu sagen. Und ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil ich mir das zu Zeiten angewöhnt habe, wo man noch viel ICQ-Text-Nachrichten geschickt hat.
Und ich habe sehr viel ICQ-Text-Nachrichten immer, immer Teile von copy-pasted, wenn man also Sachen, die sich wiederholt haben und so.
Und da hatte ich immer Schiss, dass ich aus versehen dem oder der Falschen, wie auch immer, dann ausversehen die falsche Nachricht schicke.
Was weiß ich, wenn ich über einen geflamed habe, wollte ich dem das nicht gerade schicken. Deswegen habe ich mir angewöhnt, mein Clipboard irgendwie leer zu machen.
Aber eigentlich, komplett dämlich. Total bescheuert, ja. Also, gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, das Ganze zu machen.
Ja, so sieht's aus. Genau, und deswegen mache ich schon mal nass jetzt wirklich ganz, ganz billig. Einfach Platte dran, nachts ersunken und gut ist.
Ich habe alles da, theoretisch. Alles, was wir damals aufgeschrieben haben, das hier habe ich gekauft.
Inklusive der Gehäuse. Ich habe mir sogar das Gehäuse gekauft, Nummer 2. Das ist ein 19 Zoll REC-Gehäuse.
Was Platz hat für zwei mini-ETX-Boards, das kleine. Das heißt, kann es quasi zwei Boards in einen 19 Zoll REC machen.
Das Gehäuse hat, glaube ich, 2 HE oder so. Das ist echt cool. Nimmt wenig Platz weg.
Wie würdest du da denn die Softwarearchitektur auf den Geräten machen? Hä? Verstehe ich nicht, was du meinst.
Nee, YouTube-Statistiken kann man uns nicht angucken. Auf YouTube weile ich hin. Das ist mein Streaming-Account. Da bin ich nirgendswo eingeloggt.
Nicht, dass man aus Versehen auch die Porn-Sammlung sieht oder sonst was.
Wann hast du das letzte Mal den Friseur RL getroffen? Das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Das ist schon ein bisschen her. Weiß ich gar nicht wann genau. Aber das ist schon ein bisschen her.
Danke für den Follow und auch danke für die ganzen Follows, die es die letzten Streams übergegeben hat.
Achso, auf dem Nass. Also mit welchem Container? Docke ATC. Ich werde auf meinem Nass gar nichts Großartiges containerisieren.
Das macht nass. Da musste nichts Großartiges vercontainern. Und wenn werde ich mir angucken, was da drauf muss.
Ja doch, das einzige was da drauf muss. Ich habe es mir doch mal irgendwo aufgeschrieben, was alles auf meinem Nass drauf musste.
Nass, Nassbild, Server. Wie habe ich das denn genannt?
Warum kann ich den nach Punkt-MD suchen, wenn das doch ganz klar eine Markdown-Datei war, die ich eben gesehen habe?
Warum kann man bei Windows nicht nach Punkt-MD suchen? Wo ist denn da jetzt der Sin-Schulm wieder drin? Guck mal hier.
Nassbild, Punkt-MD. Und ich suche nach Punkt-MD. Finde ich immer nach Stansion, Punkt-MD suchen.
Was ist denn das schon wieder für ein Windows-Crap? Und nach MD. Was ist denn das schon wieder für ein Stoss?
Guck mal mal ins Verzeichnis, wo wir das gemacht haben. Oh, da ist viel. Nassbild, Netzwerk, Internet, TXT.
Ja, keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt jetzt. Da will ich nicht reingucken, weil da weiß ich nicht was drinnen ist.
Ah ja, doch hier steht es doch. Hier steht es doch, was ich alles auf die unterschiedlichen Kisten machen wollte.
Genau, auf die eine Kiste muss Nextcloud drauf, Nass kommt drauf, die Backup-Geschichte kommt drauf,
PXE-Boot-Server kommt drauf, Gitfronted kommt drauf, Fritzbox, Kontakt-Sync, Anruf-Monitor kommt drauf und IMAP-Mail-Backup.
Das meiste werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht verdockern, weil man muss es mit Container nicht übertreiben.
Wenn ich einfach in Binary starten muss, dann muss ich das nicht im Docker-Container packen. Man kann es wirklich übertreiben.
Ich sehe teilweise, was die Leute heute in Docker-Container packen, nach dem Motto, ich brauche mal ein Tool, mit dem ich CSV-Dateien aufsplitte.
Das wird nicht einfach gestartet, dann wird erst mal ein Docker-Container runtergeladen und gestartet, damit man das dann machen kann.
Das ist ein bisschen übertrieben. Das Gitfronted-Geschichte überlege ich mir.
Aber je nachdem, was ich damit machen will, kommt es entweder in Docker-Container rein oder in LXD-Container.
Dann ist es mehr so wie eine eigene Installation.
Und Nextcloud kommt relativ sicher nicht in den Docker-Container, weil die immer noch Probleme mit dem Nextcloud-Update in Containern haben.
Also in den Docker-Container.
Die neuen Raspberry Pi habe ich noch nicht. Ich wollte mir jetzt eigentlich mal im Stream angucken.
Also ich habe den heute Morgen bestellt. Ich hatte Glück. Ich war wohl einer der Letzten, der im Shop noch eingekriegt hat.
Aktuell gibt es, glaube ich, noch welche bei Heise. Heiseshop.
Also wenn ihr einen wollt, ich glaube im Heiseshop gibt es, kriegt ihr noch welche.
Die gibt es ja jetzt im Windows-Store. Du meinst nicht den Raspberry, oder? Den wird es nicht im Windows-Store geben.
Was ist ein Docker-Container? Du musst Docker weglassen. Was ist ein Container?
Da geht es um LXD-Container, also sprich um Linux-Container.
Das ist, Docker ist im Endeffekt nur ein Frontend dafür.
Unter der Haube ist jegliche Container-Virtualisierung oder jegliche Containerisierung kornelmäßig Linux-mäßig der gleiche Kram.
Das ist alles LXD. Sie haben es halt ein bisschen kompliziert gemacht, weil LXD gibt es einmal quasi als Frontend-Tools zum Container anlegen.
Allerdings nennt man auch die Sache im kernel LXD.
Das ist im Prinzip ein bisschen wie eine VM, allerdings mit dem Unterschied, dass keinerlei Hardware zusätzlich virtualisiert oder emuliert wird.
Es wird eigentlich nur das Programm, was du normalerweise auf deinem System starten würdest, kriegt vorgegaukelt.
Es würde quasi isoliert auf einem anderen System laufen, ohne dass es das wirklich tut.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass es natürlich deutlich schneller ist, also viel viel schneller als VMs, weil man mit VMs normalerweise auch keine großen Leistungsprobleme hat.
Es ist viel viel schneller als VMs und es braucht theoretisch auch weniger Ressourcen drum herum als eine VM.
Dafür ist es auch nicht so gut isoliert wie eine VM.
Also ich habe hier die 4GB Version. Ich gucke mal kurz in meine Mails, ob das...
Also angeblich liefern die bis zum nächsten Werktag. Ich habe es hier bestellt. Ich habe es hier bestellt.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob die Versandbestätigung schon raus ist.
Ich habe eine extra E-Mail, wo ich alle Versandbestätigungen von allen Shops hinschicken lasse und die rufe ich nicht so oft ab.
Da habe ich gerade abgerufen, 490 neue Mails.
4 lunch. Jetzt habe ich in Damien alles bestellt. Ach du Scheiße.
Na gut, es ist auch schon ein Monat her und ich habe viel Kleinkram bestellt.
Apropos E-Mail. Ja, ja, war ich mir eher Gedanken drüber sehbarer.
So, ich muss jetzt mal gucken, ob die den Kram schon verschickt haben.
Ihre Bestellung wurde versandt. Oh, schon um 12.57 Uhr haben die die verschickt. Die waren ja richtig schnell.
Ich habe es um 9.11 Uhr bestellt und um 12.57 Uhr haben sie die verschickt.
Ach guck mal, die haben noch was. Ach, das ist der Englische.
Haha, nee, nee, nee, nee.
DE müssen wir gucken.
Haben die noch was?
Ausverkauft, ausverkauft, ausverkauft. Oh, RIP.
Also bei denen gibt es nichts, aber wie gesagt im Heiser Store gibt es noch welche.
Angeblich.
Oh, da steht ja gar keine Verfügbarkeit dran. Das ist natürlich ganz schön knack.
Und ach ja, denkt dran, ihr braucht einen Netzteil mit USB-C oder einen Adapter. Das ist jetzt neu.
Genau, und was ich eigentlich mit ihm streamen machen wollte, ich wollte mir mit euch mal angucken, was das Ding Neues hat.
Und morgen, wenn er dann da ist, dann können wir uns heute überlegen, was wir da drauf ausprobieren wollen.
Ich habe mir nämlich schon ein paar Sachen überlegt, also wir wollen da nichts wirklich drauf installieren, wir wollen testen, was es kann.
Also ich habe mir schon ein paar Sachen überlegt, was wir auf jeden Fall testen müssen.
Und zwar ist das, wir müssen testen, was das Ding an USB-Performance bringt. Das werden wir ganz einfach machen.
Dann nehmen wir einen USB auf den SATA Adapter und machen eine SSD dran.
Ja, der verbraucht jetzt auch mehr Strom.
Allerdings dürften 10 Watt wirklich nur im äußersten Ausnahmefall sein.
Aber er braucht angeblich eidel auch ein bisschen mehr Strom als der alte.
Das habe ich schon gelesen, aber wir gucken uns das jetzt gleich mal zusammen an, was die so geschrieben haben.
Genau, und was wir dann auch noch ausprobieren können, wie sehr sich das Ding dann theoretisch für Netzwerkspeicher eignen würde.
Ich weiß, dass nämlich viele Leute darauf schielen, mit dem Raspberry...
Also eigentlich, was viele Leute mit dem Raspberry gerne machen wollen, was bisher nicht geht, war einmal Netzwerkspeicher und einmal...
Ja, ich habe gesagt, das geht nicht, das geht schon als Mediakiste.
Allerdings muss man sagen, auch wenn Kodi wunderbar gelaufen ist bisher auf dem Raspberry, wirklich Spaß gemacht hat das Ganze nicht.
Ich habe das auch mal ausprobiert, und es war auch schon der 3er.
Das ist einfach ziemlich hakelig und die 3D-Besteunigung ist gefühlt auch nicht vorhanden.
Also schön ist es nicht.
So, und das müsste jetzt mit dem neuen deutlich besser sein.
Zumal der neue jetzt auch Hardware-Decoding hat für H.265.
Für VP9 leider nicht.
Ja, bevor wir uns dann gucken, was wir morgen dann auch testen müssen.
Also wenn euch was einfällt, sagt Bescheid.
Ich habe mir jetzt aktuell überlegt, wir gucken morgen mal, wenn der Raspberry da ist.
Der ist auf jeden Fall da, das Ding wurde um 12.57 Uhr heute verschickt.
Also, würde mich schon sehr wundern, wenn das nicht ankommt morgen.
Also wir testen mal USB mit einem USB-Susata-Converter mit einer ordentlichen SSD dran.
Die SSD sollte deutlich schneller sein als der USB-Anschluss.
Sollte ihn zumindest gut auslasten können.
Dann können wir mal testen, habe ich mal aufgeschrieben, wie das denn mit Port-Channel bzw. Bonding wäre.
Also sprich, wir könnten mal gucken, wenn wir hier jetzt an die zwei USB-3-Anschlüsse, wenn wir da jetzt...
Oder sagen wir mal so, wenn wir an einen USB-3-Anschluss einen Dual-Port-Gigabit-Adapter dranhängen.
Ja, sowas gibt es.
Also man kann mittlerweile, es gibt USB-3-Dual-Port-Gigabit-Adapter.
Da hätten wir ja theoretisch 3x 1 Gigabit.
Und da können wir das mal an einen Switch hängen und gucken, wie schnell das dann auch ist, wenn man die Ports zusammen bindet.
Wie viel da drüber geht.
Dann werden wir morgen auch noch testen, wie schnell das Ding überhaupt dann auf so eine SSD lesen, schreiben, sonst was kann.
Und natürlich auch, wie es das verschlüsselt kann und wie es das mit Samba kann bzw. mit verschlüsselter Platte über Samba.
Das ist eigentlich immer so der Knackpunkt.
Also in der Regel ist es, egal was du hast, immer durch die Schnitt...
Also meistens durch die Schnittstelle beschränkt, wenn du einfach auf eine unverschlüsselte Platte irgendeinen Mist draufschreibst.
Das ist eigentlich das geht.
Also wenn du da Nullen draufschreibst, dann bist du eigentlich immer durch die Schnittstelle beschränkt.
Normalerweise.
Wenn du die Platte verschlüsselt hast, dann kommt es ein bisschen drauf an, was du verwendest.
Wenn du so 0815 Zeug verwendest, was die jeweilige Kiste hardwarebeschleunigt drauf hat, dann geht das auch noch.
Aber es ist meistens schon mal eine ganze Ecke langsamer.
Also eine ganze Ecke, so 15% oder sowas.
Aber meistens ist immer noch schnell genug für die jeweilige Schnittstelle.
Wo es dann lustig wird, ist, wenn du das Ganze über den Windows, über den Samba Fileshare machst.
Weil das ist bis heute noch nicht richtig multithreaded.
Das Einzige, was die Jungs bei Samba, glaube ich, hingekriegt haben, ist,
dass die IO und Netzwerk in zwei verschiedenen Threads machen können.
Allerdings beschränkt das trotzdem ganz schön.
Und wenn dazu noch kommt, dass das Ganze verschlüsselt ist,
dann brummt die CPU meistens ordentlich.
Und ob wir dann noch Gigabit erreichen, da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Aber das probieren wir morgen mal aus.
Und je nachdem, was euch noch einfällt.
Das sind so die Sachen, die ich mir jetzt überlegt habe.
Wir werden so ein paar 0815 CPU Benchmarks machen oder sowas.
Komplettes Kit ist ausverkauft.
Ja, kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Aber du brauchst kein komplettes Kit.
Du kannst ja einfach auch einen Mikro-USB auf USB-C Adapter holen für 50 Cent oder so.
Ich habe mir auch kein neues Netzteil geholt.
Ich habe hier noch USB-Kabel mit USB-C.
Aber man kann sich auch einfach einen Mikro-USB auf USB-C holen.
So was hier.
Aber es gibt noch viel günstigere.
Das sind dann einfach so Aufstecker.
Ja, hier.
Zehn Stück.
699.
Man kann den Raspberry dann auch dran anschließen oder sowas hier.
So, und jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was denn da drin ist.
Weil ich habe es mir nur so am Rande angeguckt.
Also ich weiß, dass er eine H.265 Decoding-Beschleunigung drauf hat.
Dass er jetzt USB-C verwendet.
Das war es im Großen und Ganzen.
Und dass es ihn jetzt mit 1, 2 und 4 Gigabit gibt.
Du kannst den Pi doch über deine Smart-Steckdose betreiben.
Ja, kann ich machen.
Also, was ist drinne?
Zeichne mal her.
Raspberry Pi 4 Model B.
Was mein ich Model B?
Model B ist die Abmaße, oder?
Oder warum muss das Model B heißen?
Ich glaube, das waren die Abmaße, oder?
Ja, genau.
Also vom Case her müsste das ins alte Case reinpassen.
Das ist ja auch kompatibel mit den alten Boards.
Also mit den alten Hats, die du drauf machen kannst.
Die wird es nicht kompatibel.
Ach Quatsch, ne.
Stimmt, du hast recht.
Das kann ja gar nicht mit dem alten Case kompatibel sein,
weil es jetzt andere Schnittstellen hat.
Stimmt.
Ja, logisch.
Ja gut, deswegen, wir müssen uns das Ganze jetzt mal angucken.
Also, was ist denn jetzt drinne?
1,5 GHz Quad-Core 64-Bit ARM Cortex A72 CPU.
Drei Mal mehr Performance.
Was war denn im Alten drin?
Ah, guck mal da.
Die 300 MHz werden nicht den Unterschied machen,
aber das ist eine neuere Version.
Oder eine neuere CPU.
Das ist ganz interessant.
Da müssen wir mal gucken,
was da der Unterschied ist.
Das sind schon zig Threads, was der Unterschied ist.
Ah, Performance-Oriented Core, blablabla.
Was?
Alter, gehen wir nicht auf den Sack.
Nein, ich disable jetzt bestimmt nicht meinen Adblocker dafür.
Das kommt gleich wieder, ich sag's euch.
Wisst ihr was?
Kann man das löschen?
Nee.
Oh, da hat's richtig gemacht, der Dude.
Na, guck mal mal hier.
Stimmt, warum nicht?
Kannst du auf Raus schalten?
Na, wenn er das clever gemacht hat, ist das aber dann...
Ich hab eigentlich Java-Skript.
Der sollte eigentlich gar nichts Java-Skript groß sein.
Ach, leckt mich.
So kack Seiten will ich, unterstütze ich gar nicht.
Ich hab keinen Bock drauf.
Also, was haben wir hier für einen Unterschied?
Out of Order?
Ah, hatte das der Alte nicht?
Sagt das allen was oder soll ich das mal versuchen zu erklären, was Out of Order Execution ist?
Also, das ist doch die Intel-Lücke.
Das hat ein bisschen was mit der Intel-Lücke bzw. mit Meltdown zu tun.
Aber eigentlich ist es was anderes.
Also, die Technik ist was komplett anderes.
Dass Intel da ein bisschen komische Dinge macht, das ist, ja, das ist was anderes.
Nee, Out of Order Execution ist eine Technik, was eine CPU ordentlich beschleunigen kann,
also zumindest den Ablauf.
Also, wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten?
Wenn ihr euch jetzt mal so ein Programm vorstellt als Bytes, ja,
so ein Programm besteht ja im Prinzip aus Instruktionen an die CPU,
was sie machen sollen, plus irgendwelche Values dazu.
Das erste ist quasi ein Opcode nennt sich das,
also quasi sowas wie addieren, subtrahieren, irgendwo anders hinspringen oder so.
Und dazu gehören dann noch irgendwelche Values.
So, und es ist manchmal nicht ganz klar, ob das, was jetzt quasi in dem Programmablauf,
in welcher Reihenfolge das tatsächlich ausgeführt werden muss, dass die Logik wieder stimmt.
Weil ich meine, nur weil in einem Programm was untereinander steht, heißt es noch lange nicht,
dass das auch nacheinander alles ausgeführt wird.
Weil da kann ein IF drinne sein oder sowas in der Richtung, ja.
So, und Out of Order Execution ist jetzt, nicht dass ich jetzt komplett ein Mist erzähle,
aber ich glaube, Out of Order Execution ist die Geschichte, die quasi einmal versucht,
nee genau, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt einmal die Technik, die versucht, ungefähr vorherzusagen,
welche Teile dieses Programms wahrscheinlich jetzt ausgeführt werden.
Man weiß es nicht, aber es könnte sein, ja.
Also die verwenden da irgendwelche, fragt mich nicht, Magic, wo sie quasi erraten,
welcher Zweig beispielsweise von einem IF jetzt wahrscheinlich ausgeführt wird.
So, und Out of Order Execution heißt, man kann schon was ausführen im Voraus,
also Out of Order, also sprich Sachen, die jetzt eigentlich gar nicht dran sind,
aber wenn die dann, wenn das die richtigen sind, die dran kommen,
dann ist gut, dann hat man es schon ausgeführt.
Ich glaube, das ist Out of Order Execution.
So ganz 100% kriegst du aus dem Kopf jetzt auch nicht hin,
aber ich glaube, es ging darum, dass du Sachen quasi schon mal ausführst im Vorfeld,
also die jetzt eigentlich nicht im Programmablauf logisch dran sind, ja.
Zum Beispiel, weil du gerade Zeit hast, was zu machen,
oder weil du auf User-Eingaben wartest oder irgendwas,
oder einfach weil es schneller geht, anstatt neue Sachen zu laden.
Klick mal aufs Fragezeichen, ja.
Ja, steht es doch da hier.
Also fast.
Alter, kannst du mal rauskopieren.
Make use of instruction sites that normally would be wasted, genau.
Wenn du auf User-Eingaben wartest oder wenn du gerade neue Sachen laden müsstest,
oder wenn du aus irgendwelchen Gründen quasi Zeit hast, was zu machen,
dann führst du einfach Dinge aus in der Hoffnung, das brauchst du.
Und wenn du es dann nicht brauchst, und das ist dann auch so ein bisschen das Problem,
was sie bei Meltdown hatten, wenn du es dann nicht brauchst,
sollte eigentlich alles wieder verworfen werden, so als hättest du es nie ausgeführt.
Das bedeutet, da der CPU führt zwar was aus, allerdings ist das rein CPU-intern.
Du siehst davon nichts.
Von außen, ja.
Also auch wenn du irgendwelche Register abfragst oder so,
das sollte nie den Zustand haben, dass du erkennen kannst, dass der irgendwas ausgewöhrt hat.
Und das ist ja das Problem, was sie bei Meltdown hatten,
dass du eben doch über irgendwelche Side-Channel-Geschichten dort Sachen rausschleusen konntest.
Ich erkläre das Falsche, der Flix-Coder wird uns das jetzt erklären.
Was hat er schon?
Also, ich lese das mal vor, was er geschrieben hat.
Out of Order ist automatisches Parallel-Ausführen, wenn mehrere Commands nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Zum Beispiel kann man add R1 und add R4 parallel ausführen.
Okay.
Das ist ein bisschen was, was ich erzählt habe, aber der Grund, warum was ausgeführt wird und wie, stimmt nicht.
Na gut, damit kann ich leben.
Ja, ist ja auch sinnvoll, wenn es...
Stimmt, du hast recht, ich erinnere mich wieder dran.
Ja, genau.
Stimmt.
Der kann irgendwie erkennen, welche Programm-Teile nichts miteinander zu tun haben und kann die dann automatisch quasi parallel ausführen.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es das gibt, was ich erklärt habe.
Ich bin jetzt plötzlich ganz sicher gewesen, ob es das ist oder was anderes.
Das ist ein recht komplexes Feld, ja.
Das ist ein recht kompliziertes Feld und wenn man sich damit jetzt nicht so unbedingt öfters beschäftigt,
kann man da schon mal Sachen miteinander bringen.
Aber das, was ich erzählt habe, gibt es auch.
Und das, was ich erzählt habe, ist auch das, was Intel ein bisschen gefickt hat bei Meltdown.
Dann ist nicht das, das, was... wo es Meltdown-Probleme gibt.
Zumindest bringt das richtig was.
Out of Order Execution.
Kannst du mal Arm Cortex A53 erklären?
Äh, das ist einfach der CPU, das ist einfach der CPU-Typ.
Das ist so wie Intel Celeron oder Intel i3 versus i5.
Das sind unterschiedliche CPUs.
Nur, dass zwischen dem und dem ein bisschen mehr Unterschied ist als zwischen dem i5 und dem i7.
Also es ist eher... ja, es ist eigentlich eher damit zu vergleichen, wenn du einen Atom vergleichst mit, sagen wir, einem Celeron oder so.
Die sind ja auch schon ziemlich unterschiedlich.
Von dem, was Intel freischaltet und drin ist.
Genau, es ist... ja, stimmt, da hat der Flo recht.
Das ist eher einfach der Unterschied zwischen zwei CPU-Generationen.
Genau, das trifft es am ehesten.
Das ist das, was ich beschreiben wollte mit Atom gegen Zelt.
Ja, das ist wie wenn du quasi jetzt den i5 hast, letzte Generation, und du hast jetzt irgendwie den i5 nächste Generation.
Das ist einfach eine neuere Ausgabe von ihrer CPU.
Was in der Regel natürlich auch einhergeht mit, dass das Ding neuere Techniken kann.
Scrolldowns, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zu...
32-Bit-Support, da wird der Raspberry wahrscheinlich keinen Gebrauch von machen, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Der Raspberry, die stehen unglaublich auf 32-Bit.
Wahrscheinlich wegen Rückwärtskompatibilität.
Okay, also der größte Unterschied ist tatsächlich, dass das Ding jetzt Out-of-Order-Execution hat.
Und wahrscheinlich, dass es ein bisschen schneller getaktet ist.
Ansonsten müssen wir im Detail nochmal gucken, weil es könnte durchaus sein, dass manche anderen Sachen einfach optimiert sind.
Ja, es ist ja auch so, jetzt mal ganz, ganz, ganz billig gesagt.
Nur weil eine CPU der letzten Generation auch, sagen wir jetzt mal, zwei Zahlen zusammenrechnen kann.
Und ne, Zahlen zusammenrechnen ist ein doofes Beispiel, das können die Dinger schon ganz schön lange ziemlich gut.
Aber wir bleiben aber dabei, nur weil eine CPU der letzten Generation zwei Zahlen zusammenrechnen kann,
und eine CPU der aktuelle Generation auch zwei Zahlen zusammenrechnen kann, heißt das nicht,
dass das unter der Haube im Prinzip immer gleich sein muss.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass ein Befehl in der alten Generation, sagen wir jetzt mal,
vier Cycles gebraucht hat und in der neuen nur noch zwei.
Gut, bei Add ist das nicht der Fall.
Aber das kann durchaus sein, das heißt, selbst wenn alte und neue CPU-Generationen gleich einen Takt haben,
kann das trotzdem sein, dass die neue CPU-Generation in manchen Bereichen deutlich schneller ist.
Das sieht man bei Intel meistens daran, wenn sie irgendwelche Special Instruction Sets wieder eingeführt haben.
Zum Beispiel, als sie ihr Hardware-beschleunigtes AIS-Zeugs eingeführt haben. Das hat einfach mal AIS-Verschlüsselung ver 50-facht von der Beschleunigung.
Also normales AIS gegen eine Variante, die AIS-NI verwendet, ist ein riesen Unterschied unter Intel.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was für ein Faktor, aber es ist enorm viel Unterschied.
Das ist so nach dem Motto, wenn du das beispielsweise auf einem Load-Balancer hast für SSL,
wenn du das vorher gemacht hast, sag ich jetzt einfach mal so aus dem Bauch raus, hast du irgendwie keine Ahnung,
300 MB durchgekriegt und mit AIS-NI kriegen sie dann 1500 MB durch oder so.
Das ist also ein riesen Unterschied manchmal. Obwohl du beides, du konntest natürlich mit beiden CPUs das vorher auch schon machen,
aber jetzt mit dem neuen Instruction Set oder den neuen Befehlen geht es einfach viel schneller.
Es kann ja natürlich immer zwischen CPU-Generationen passieren, dass die auch Sachen können, die die alte CPU auch kann,
allerdings einfach schneller ist damit und ohne dass der Takt schneller ist.
Ich meine, CPU kann auch in anderen Bereichen schneller werden, außer dem Takt.
Haben wir in den letzten Jahren gesehen, der Takt hat sich gar nicht so viel geändert.
Dank Intel die Geschwindigkeit auch nicht, aber prinzipiell hat sich trotzdem vieles an der Technik getan in den letzten 10 Jahren,
auch wenn es vom Takt her nicht so viel gewesen ist.
Der Takt ist noch minimal schneller geworden.
Wir haben viel mehr Kerne gekriegt und wir haben aber auch optimierte CPUs gekriegt.
So, wir wollen noch weiter gucken, was ist sonst noch drinnen.
Okay, das mit dreimal Performance genießen, wenn man mit Vorsicht, wir können es morgen exakt ausprobieren.
Ich habe mir, ich wollte gerade sagen glücklicherweise, aber eigentlich war der Zeitpunkt, mir vor zwei Wochen nochmal zwei neue Raspberry Pi 3er Sets zu kaufen.
Ziemlich bescheuert, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber dafür habe ich jetzt zwei Raspberries noch da und da können wir dreier, also die letzten dreier,
da können wir morgen mal genau ausprobieren, wie schnell die CPUs wirklich sind im Vergleich zu dem anderen.
Und ich wette, ich könnte fast wetten, dass bei einem ordentlichen CPU-Benchmark die Performance nicht dreimal ist.
Oder vielleicht gerade halt in dem Benchmark dreimal ist oder unter realen Bedingungen nicht.
Aber ich glaube noch nicht mal in dem Benchmark mal drei.
Da müssen dann wahrscheinlich schon ganz spezielle Bedingungen sein, dass das funktioniert.
Wo sind die Overwatch-Streams?
Overwatch, that game.
Ich habe gehört, Overwatch hat jetzt einen Replay-Modus, der angeblich, jetzt kommt wieder der Blizzard, es gibt den Nintendo-Haken und es gibt den Blizzard-Haken.
Der Blizzard-Haken ist, dass sie immer Sachen, die offensichtlich sind, scheiße machen.
Das ist bei Nintendo anders, bei Nintendo denkst du schon von Anfang an, es gibt es gar nicht und dann freust du dich, dass es es doch gibt.
Und dann ist der Multiplayer doch scheiße. Aber zum Beispiel, Replay-Modus von Overwatch habe ich gehört, dass man das nicht replayen kann, wenn man im Duo gespielt hat.
Was ja schon mal komplett beklagt ist.
Man möchte Teamfights replayen, wenn man besser werden will und nicht solo queue.
Weil, dass man solo queue replayen kann, ist auch gut, ja. Aber warum kann man nicht replayen? Na, angeblich geht das nicht, wenn man im Duo drin ist.
Das habe ich gestern erst im Stream gesehen, dass man nicht replayen kann, wenn man Duo gequeued hat mit jemand anderem.
Ach, man kann in der Gruppe nicht den Modus bedrehen.
Geht das aber auch blöd. Also okay, ist es nicht ganz so blöd wie vorher. Okay, der Blizzard-Hacken ist nicht so groß.
Aber es ist trotzdem doof, dass man das in der Gruppe sich nicht angucken kann, weil gerade dafür willst du das als Team wahrscheinlich verwenden.
Hast du mal das neue Arno ausprobiert? Ja, macht Bock, macht richtig Bock. Ist aber nichts für ein Streben, sowas für alleine spielen.
Ja, Chattos, das stimmt. Vor allem, man muss das in der Gruppe nicht angucken.
Ja, Chattos, das stimmt. Vor allem, man muss sich mal überlegen, und das ist jetzt auch so, das ist jetzt auch ein Blizzard-Hacken, den ich ja selbst mitgekriegt habe.
Das heißt, das kann ich jetzt nicht mal vom Hören sagen, dass sie vor allem bei Overwatch für alles ewig brauchen.
Ewig. Ich meine, wann kam das Game raus? 2017 oder so?
Wann habe ich mein erstes Overwatch-Gameplay aus der Beta hochgeladen?
Das ist Beta-Gameplay. Guck mal, Februar 2016. Das war Beta-Gameplay hier damals noch.
So, das heißt, die haben jetzt, wenn man die Beta mitrechnet, wo sie das mit dem Replay-Modus ja auch schon wussten, die haben jetzt drei Jahre gebraucht, um den Replay-Modus einzubauen.
Und vieles geht in Overwatch einfach kort und langsam.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns bei Raspberry weiter an.
Was sagst du zu Cyberpunk 2077, was du bisher gesehen hast? Ja, Keanu Reeves ist nice.
Allerdings ist Cyberpunk gerade so das Setting an Games, was mir persönlich nicht gefällt.
Das sagt nichts zu der Qualität des Spiels aus. Ich gehe davon aus, das Spiel an sich wird top sein.
Und ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass ich mir kaufen werde, weil ich Witcher 3 auch gut fand.
Und es dann mir auch gefällt, aber eigentlich ist es ein Setting, was mir nicht gefällt.
Ja, das stimmt, wenn Blizzard was macht und es fertig ist, dann ist es in der Regel fertig, aber die brauchen ewig.
Und haben auch irgendwie kein richtiges Gespür für mehr, was die Leute wollen.
Und generell auch kein Gespür mehr für gescheite Games.
Also, rückwirkend muss ich fast sagen, so das letzte gute Game, was von Blizzard rausgekommen ist.
Wenn man man Overwatch außen vor lässt, was eigentlich seit Anfang an seine Probleme hat,
war eigentlich das erste, das originale StarCraft 2.
Das war eigentlich das letzte gute Blizzard Game.
Was so richtig alles irgendwie hatte, was man da gewohnt war.
Der Gespür für Balancing auch nicht.
Der Anfang von Overwatch, der war nur top, wenn man das Spiel noch nicht gespielt hat vorher.
Ich habe ja viel Beta gespielt und ähm...
Overwatch braucht ein bisschen, bis man rausgekriegt hat, was einem auf den Sack geht.
Aber dafür geht es einem dann massiv auf den Sack.
Ich kenne kein Spiel, wo die Pros selber so ungern spielen wie Overwatch.
Das hat schon was zu bedeuten.
Ich meine, sie kriegen zwar immer den Maulkorb an und kaum einer äußert sich zu,
aber wenn sich mal einer zu äußert, dann kommt genau das raus.
Okay, also, was haben wir? Hab ich jetzt was?
Sollte Overwatch 2 geben? Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab bloß mal gelesen, dass das da gerade, dass gerade am Überlegen sind.
Hab ich irgendwas übersehen im Chat?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich meine, guckt euch allein schonmal manche Overwatch-Maps an.
Ah.
Wenn die uns, wenn die den ordentlichen Map-Editor hätten.
Wo, und halt auch nicht, dieses, äh dieses, äh vom Blizzard-gesteuerte eSport-Geschichte.
da würden die leuten nur custom maps spielen und keine offiziellen maps
bis auf ein paar
du hattest beide recht mit anthem von EA
dass es kacke wird
also wenn ich mich richtig erinnere was ich damals gesagt habe bei dem ersten
trailer von anthem war
dass es für mich übelst wie so das retorten game aussieht
so quasi
man macht ein game
weiß eigentlich gar nicht genau was man machen will
baut irgendwie so alles ein was gut klingt
so quasi so dass das das das uninspirierteste
game aller zeiten so sah für mich der erste anthem gameplay trailer aus
und es wurde dann auch kacke
und wer da stimmt was das ebaro sagt ist jetzt auch schon dead
so ich wollte mir eigentlich die hartverdaten vom respiratory angucken
denkst du die zunehmende
seasonisierung der games
positive oder negative entwicklung das kommt ganz auf das game an
also was ich was ich beknackt finde ist sowas wie battlefield 5
game kommt raus ist es kaum was drinne ich weiß man muss sich mal überlegen
lasst euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen
battlefield 5
kam raus
hatte im hauptmenü den knopf für firing range
also da konntest du trainings map halt wo man mit waffen üben kann
und wenn du
die ersten paar wochen in battlefield 5
auf das icon für firing range gedrückt hast im hauptmenü
kam ein pop-up wo drin stand coming soon
jetzt lasst euch das mal auf der zunge zergehen
in dem neuen battlefield haben die im hauptmenü einen knopf
für eine map auf der man waffen testen kann das was in jedem spiel drinne ist
seit in jedem games und multiplayer shooting in jedem solange ich denken kann
und es ist im hauptmenü drinne
aber wenn du draufklickst kommt coming soon
sprich die haben es geschafft battlefield 5 zu releasen
ohne eine funktionierende firing range und obwohl das im hauptmenü drinne stand
also das muss er erstmal auf die reihe kriegen
also wie sie es in battlefield machen finde ich total hängen geblieben in
battlefield 5
auch diese geschichte mit hoho guck mal her wir haben jetzt rush
ja aber wir haben rush nur für irgendwie drei wochen das danach ist rush wieder weg
das ist doppelt das ist doppelt drauf gekackt auf das game nämlich erstens
für die leute
die das entwickelt haben
es wird wahrscheinlich nicht einer auf dem klo gesessen haben und in seiner
mittagspause mal kurz rush implement in battlefield 5
da werden schon ein paar leute eine ganze weile daran gearbeitet haben dass das
ordentlich funktioniert
für die ist es scheiße dass quasi ihr neuer spielmodus einfach mal ins game kommt
danach wieder verschwindet
und für die spieler ist es auch scheiße
magst du halt wieder wenig am abschweifen ja
ja was willst du machen ja das was willst du
ich bin der meister im gesidetracked werden das wisst ihr doch
ja wir machen jetzt aber wirklich erstmal die
die die handband fertig
wenn du noch was wissen wollt oder noch irgendwelche themen habt oder irgendwas
wissen wir schreibt in den chat rein mit ad wo bloß dann
dann guck ich mir an ich scroll hoch
so und jetzt gucken wir uns die art weiter an
wenn es beim launch keine
äh
ln2 ist das wasserkühlung oder ist das ist das flüssiges ähm
ist das stickstoff
ln2
ln2 ist stickstoff oder
ja ist klar der raspberry muss unbedingt stickstoff kühlt werden
ok tommy können wir gleich machen
ähm ok was haben wir
endlich
endlich ordentliches gigabit
manch einer wird jetzt sagen ey max
raspberry pi 3 der der letzte hatte auch schon gigabit
aber unter der haube war es nie gigabit
unter der haube war es immer nur um so donation
ähm
keine nachricht damit max vom thema bleibt wollte keine oder kleine
nachricht schreiben
zumindest das ist sehr nice
das ist das ist ultra nice hier
das heißt das ding ist jetzt nicht mehr irgendwie an usb 2 angebunden
oder sonst wie sondern ein ordentlicher gigabit anschluss
das ist sehr schön
ob es intern an usb 3 hängt ist mir ehrlich gesagt scheißegal
hauptsache ein ordentlicher gigabit anschluss für das teil
also sprich leute aus dem kopf
maximale megabyte pro sekunde gigabit
5 sekunden zeit
125 der sebarer hat gewonnen
da hab ich letztens
ja das kann ich jetzt ja mal erzählen
hab ich letztens als hubi bei uns ein bisschen
bisschen aus versehen eigentlich aus dem konzept gebracht der wollte seine
seine abschluss präsentation mal halten ja
und habe ich mir gedacht jetzt stellst du immer so eine ganz doofe frage so wie es
die ihk auch macht
der hat als abschlussprojekt hat der einen einen storage
grob gesagt ein storage cluster aufgebaut ist egal mit welcher
technik mit dem pfeilsystem
und
da hat er dann ein bild drin gehabt
wo er irgendwie gezeigt hat
dass die
das in seinem benchmark
dieser cluster irgendwie 300 megabyte transferieren kann
in der sekunde
und da habe ich ihn gefragt was
was meinst du so
was ist so das maximale weil er hat immer erzählt dass in gigabit netzbergkarten
drinne
so habe ich halt gefragt was meinst du denn was ist denn so das maximale was durch gigabit
durchpasst
da hat er erst mal überlegt überlegt überlegt
und habe ich dann ja ok noch einfacher
ist es nah dran an 300 oder weit weg von 300
ist er irgendwann auch drauf gekommen dass ein benchmark relativ wenig sinn
ergibt in kombination mit gigabit
weil 125 ist Schluss wenn er 300 hatte ist ein bisschen viel
ich mein
er konnte es dann auch erklären warum es 300 hat aber es ging aus dem bild nicht
nicht wirklich wirklich hervor
obwohl man auch die leute immer wunderbar schocken kann auch wenn ich das
selbst
nicht mag und
dafür eine bescheuerte frage halte aber
bei der ihk prüfung fragen sie das gerne
wenn die nämlich nicht wissen was er euch fragen sollen dann fragen sie sich
ja also ihr projekt ist ja schon sehr sehr netzwerk lastig auf welcher
schicht das osi modell bewegt sich denn ihr projekt so
das ist eine komplett scheiß frage ja
aber so ein kack wirst du da gefragt
da musst du ja irgendwas zusammenreiben dann
auf allen ist keine keine antwort
wenn wenn einer sagt auf allen dann dann musste auch noch erklären was genau auf
allen passiert
ok ich gucke mir gleich die ganzen fragen
ich muss jetzt erstmal erstmal hier erstmal den den raspberry weiter gucken
also endlich volles
ob ich heute auf einmal mehr zuschauer als am samstag dachte samstags gucken
gut
wie ich will mich jetzt
beschwer mich jetzt nicht
am
also das ist sehr gut das hier ist auch sehr nice dual band das heißt man kann
2,4 und 5
gigahertz
acht dings ac ich kann mir die wlan standard immer aus dem kopf nicht merken
aber das ist ja 5 gigahertz
das ist sehr sehr nice
lotus 5 ist auch nice ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht was was da in der
zwischenzeit passiert ist
dann die lull geht wieder
als ruhig da bleiben
ich habe genug platz
zuschauer
also ich habe gehört
bei 3000 zuschauer ist kepp
im stream wenn man nicht gepartnert ist
wir sollten mal probieren ob wir das hinkriegen
so was haben wir als nächstes 2 usb 3 das ist natürlich auch sehr praktisch
2 usb 2 ports ja gut
2 ports werden an sich ein bisschen zu langsam gewesen
aber
das ist eigentlich eine kombination die finde ich gut
2 mal usb 3
2 mal usb 2 damit kann ich leben im zweifelsfall kann man sich auch noch einen hub
anschließen dann ist gut
das ist eine sache die mich jetzt wirklich überrascht
dual monitor support
mit 4k
ich wüsste jetzt aus dem
stand
nicht
wofür ich das am raspberry brauche
hat irgendeiner von euch eine idee
hat jemand eine ernsthafte idee
es war klar dass das ist das ein schon gar nicht frage
auf dem theater pc ja aber da brauche ich eigentlich auch keine 2 monitor
also ich habe noch nicht so wirklich die da sein
berechtigung für
dual monitor support gefunden allerdings
besser haben als nicht haben wenn man es braucht
ja aber bild bearbeitung machst du auf dem raspberry nicht
also ich weiß nicht wofür das wirklich gut ist ehrlich gesagt
ein 4k ist schon mal nicht schlecht
werbefilme mit verschiedenen darstellungen in kinos haben die kinos laufen nicht
auf raspberry
besser haben als brauchen ja das denke ich auch in der richtung
video recordings graphics support opengl es 3 0 ja ok
4k 60 fps hardware decode of havoc
das ist h265 glaube ich
das ist sehr gut
das ist sehr gut das macht
so viele
mediacenter geschichten deutlich praktischer
auch wenn
h265 material doch relativ selten ist aber das ist im komm
das ist natürlich ultra wichtig
dass die das die ganzen alt
alten raspberry pi sachen noch funktionieren also vor allem die bords
und so was was es gibt
da war aber von auszugehen
da war von auszugehen
nachdem jetzt fast die die die fragen vom chat wieder verschwunden sind oben
muss ich muss ich gerade noch mal abarbeiten nicht das nicht dass es jetzt
verschwindet
ähm
tommy das offer watch video können wir uns können wir uns gleich noch angucken
wenn ich wenn wir hier fertig sind
ähm
warum lehnt du die twitch streams nicht auf youtube hoch weil ich denke dass es
die meisten leute auf youtube nicht interessiert
du brauchst eine queue die alle wupplors nach speichern und die als
benachrichtigung in dein ui einzeigt
aber das ist eine richtig gute idee kalif
als doch kalif oder
die kalf nicht kalif
der kalf
nicht der kalif
ähm
das ist eine gute idee schreibe ich mir auf
das ist doch eine richtig geile idee das könnte man mal das könnte man mal
programmieren
ähm
das ist eine
eine richtig gute idee
mich würde nicht wundern
mich würde nicht wundern wenn das wenn das irgendwie einer der
der bots oder oder ähm tippi stream oder sowas
äh wenn die das nicht schon könnten
könnte man mal gucken aber mal schauen
aber sowas selbst das finde ich ist eine richtig gute idee dass das zu
programmieren
das können wir machen
progers
progers easy progers
bist du schon mit der hardware beschleunigung sprache v h d l
in büro nein sagt mir gar nichts
wie findest du den raspberry pi store und willst du den in england mal
besuchen ich finde cool dass es sowas gibt
ich habe das heute morgen auch zum ersten mal erfahren dass es einen
offiziellen raspberry pi store gibt
aber zieht es mich jetzt nicht hin was soll ich da machen
meinungen zum reboot von modern warfare neue engine kontroverse story
oder können ich jetzt viel drüber erzählen das schreibe ich mir mal das
sage ich nachher was zu wenn wir den
den raspberry wenn wir den fertig haben
support für remote verbindung zwei monitors ja vielleicht also
ich denke in dem fall ist er zwei monitor support einfach nice to have
als ob du die natalien wiederfindest
also ich finde das finde das mit dem mit dem mit der q prog haben wir eine
wirklich gute idee
ähm
was heißt
voll duplex also full duplex ist eh alles heutzutage
halb duplex gibt's halb duplex
macht keiner mehr
wozu solltest du über twisted pair noch halb duplex machen
die meinen damit dass es nicht mehr so ein verkrüppeltes gigabit ethernet ist
was über
usb 2 intern angebunden ist
so gucken wir mal weiter
ähm moinser
140 leute
das berlin vier pack
seinen paint ich habe ich gestern in irgendeinem chat gesehen
ich weiß nicht mehr wo
jetzt aber jetzt wo ich den namen lese fällt mir das ein ich habe sich bei
den bei den im chat im chat gestern irgendwo gesehen
auf twitch
doch ja beim lost genauer beim lost
oder dieses komische
ähm
enten abschieß
mohon 2 null game gespielt hat
ok was haben wir sonst noch nicht geblieben memory options 1 gigabyte 2 gigabyte
moment
schon toll
das ist einfach mal bei uns die 1 gigabyte version so viel kostet wie die 2
gigabyte version
die denken sich auch easy money easy life
ähm
die gmb also den habe ich geholt heute noch
also 4 gigabyte und aktuell also die die alten hatten soweit ich weiß nur
1 g speicher auch der letzte dreier hatte nur 1 g speicher
damit hatten viele leute probleme ich nicht muss ich sagen ich habe auf meinen
raspberries nie irgendwie jetzt
ähm
irgendwelche langzeit datensätze die in influx db oder irgendwie ein riesen
grafana oder sowas drauf laufen gehabt
ich hatte mir nie großartig ähm
arbeitsspeicher
engpässe
allerdings
wenn man sowas drauf macht kann ich verstehen dass man an die grenzen
gekommen ist
und da sind 4 g wirklich sehr nice
weil leistungsmäßig reicht dick aus hatte der alte auch schon dafür
ausgereicht
allerdings ein bisschen wenig ram
mit 4 gigabyte ram könnte ja sogar mal zfs laufen lassen auf raspberry
einfach weil es geht
hast du schon einen möglichen verwendungszweck für den raspberry pi 4
ich habe mir erst mal einen bestellt auch die version mit 4 gigabyte also
ich hatte mir ja zwei neue
leider letzte woche oder vorletzte woche erst gekauft
ähm raspberry pi 3
der eine war
es ist für mein lorra gateway gedacht und der andere
da wollte ich den den den old octopi
dings raspberry mit ersetzen
beides
braucht die leistung und die fähigkeiten von raspberry pi 4 nicht
also nee hab ich noch nicht
wofür wird ein raspberry pi verwendet
naja im prinzip läuft ja dann vollwertiges linux drauf
also kannst du ihn für so ziemlich alles verwenden wofür du halt
was du unter linux so machst
du langst jetzt grad nicht irgendwelche 3d render geschichten sind oder
sachen die ultra viel cpu oder ram brauchen
wenn du heim automatisierungsgeschichten machst ist zum beispiel raspberry gut
oder wenn du dir zum beispiel
wenn du irgendwie sagen wir mal deine
irgendwas kleines hosten willst bei dir
mein kraftserver oder
bei keine ahnung wie gut das da drauf läuft
oder irgendwas
ich hab ich hab
wenige wenige raspberry pi ist bei mir im einsatz die normalen
ich hab eigentlich nur
den den octopi das ist ein
vollwertiger raspberry
ansonsten habe ich nur noch ein paar zeros rumhängen
weil ich da für alle nicht die volle rechenleistung brauche
lagcraft
hat sie doch drauf laufen lassen auf dem neuen bestimmt sogar ganz gut
so ein bisschen mehr mein kraft ist bestimmt was was von mit dem mehr ram
ordentlich
profitiert
wenn ich das richtig erinnere aber treibst du ein homos ist ja in einem
lxc-container
wie bekommst du die signale der aktoren sensoren da rein
ähm
ich hatte mein home assistant
ich überleg gerade hatte ich den jemals in einem lxc-container
also lxc-container von
jetzt nicht kornel seit ich sondern so
bei kornel seit ich ja alles lxc
ich überleg gerade hatte ich den schon mal
den letzten home assistant hatte ich ganz normal in der kvm vm drinnen
und aktuell ist es das offizielle has
has iow
docker gedöns bloß dass ich nicht
dass das das has iow image hab
sondern auf einem standard linux x86 linux server
has iow installiert hab das ist ganz normal der docker krempel
ich hab mein anderes
mein anderes zeug hab ich auf auf lxd laufen
allerdings ist der zugriff auf lxd-container
oder auf lxd lxd ist eigentlich das was im kornel drin ist
lxd ist diese geschichte von von canonical
also die eher sind wie eine
eigene vm
als wie so ein
docker-container
da ist der zugriff eigentlich fast noch einfacher drauf
weil das ding hat eine feste ip
kannst du sogar ssh zugriff darauf einrichten
die sachen beinden sich alle an das interface das heißt du kannst auch
direkt mit der ip alles ansprechen
ähm
aber unabhängig davon worauf es läuft
nachdem das
ganz normaler docker-container ist sind die ports einfach weitergeleitet
die ich brauche
und du brauchst ja eigentlich
für ähm
damit du damit du deine werte ordentlich in home assistant rein kriegst
gibt es eigentlich so zwei zachen die man in der regel hat
du hast einmal einen am besten natürlich als has-io addon
hast du noch einen mqtt server laufen
als als message queue
wo halt auch dein home assistant dranhängt
und du hast ähm
einen api key für home assistant
da brauchst du dann port
3123 ist es glaube ich
da kannst du einfach in den post deinen home assistant schicken und kriegst deine werte rein
du kannst allerdings home assistant auch
das habe ich auch bei einer sache
äh sowohl
rest api pullen lassen als auch normale
htp request pullen lassen
mags dein bestellverhalten ist fast so schlimm wie meins ja ich
ich hab mir in letzter zeit ich hab es euch doch gerade vorhin gesagt
94 oder 96 mail bestellungs mails jetzt innerhalb von einem monat
viel kleinscheiß dabei ja
aber ähm
so viel unsinnigen stuss gekauft wieder
ich verstehe gerade nur server
ja wenn du konkret was willst dann musst du mich fragen
es ist manchmal schwierig
also es fällt mir wirklich schwierig manche sachen wenn einer fragt
was ich mit meinen lxt-containern machen
das dann zu erklären quasi so dass jeder versteht
paypal halt
mittlerweile versuche ich alles über paypal pay oder oder amazon pay oder wie
das kram heißt
wie heißt das paypal nicht paypal pay
keine ahnung du kannst über paypal direkt check out machen
inklusive adresse und alles und kannst du über amazon mittlerweile auch über
amazon pay check out und alles machen das finde ich ist am praktischsten
ok also jetzt nochmal zurück zum rest api ich hab mir noch interessante
fragen aufgeschrieben hier
für für
dann wenn wir nix zum labern haben
wobei es heute so aussieht als geht mir das material nur wirklich nicht aus
der paketboot ist stammgast klar den kennt er kennt mich
ich kann den auch mittlerweile schon
der gibt mir sogar manchmal pakete auf der straße wenn ich da grad lang laufe
und da steht das
hab was
aber ein paketboot ist übelst groß
der ist glaube ich zwei meter drei oder so
der kann quasi durchs fenster gucken im erdgeschoss
von der straße aus
dann die pakete geben
bald wird die postfiliale einfach aus effizienzgründen bald hier nebenan aufgemacht
unabhängig von effizienzgründen
die dhl filiale ist wirklich 30 meter weg
also dort wo die sachen abgegeben werden wenn ich nicht da bin
aber es kommt kaum vor dass da sachen abgeholt dass ich da sachen abhole
weil
ich kann die leute da nicht leiden
die sind nervig
aber ich hab es im letzten stream schon gesagt ich kann
keine leute leiden
max location liegt neben dhl
ok blablabla
new raspberry pi 4 features
gibt es jetzt eigentlich auch ein neues raspian? müssen wir da gleich mal gucken
weil es wird mal wieder zeit
wird mal wieder zeit
als letztes
ist ja schon bisschen älter basiert auf stretch
buster ist das neue debian ich weiß nicht ob
buster schon raus ist ich glaube das ist noch nicht raus aber die könnten
trotzdem mal ein neues raspian rausbringen
neue features blablabla blablabla
power
jetzt haben wir es hier
sie sind von einem micro usb zu einem usb c power connector geswitcht und zwar
weil das noch mal zusätzliche 500 milliampere bringt
da muss das ding aber ordentlich brummen
1,2 ampere ist schon heftig für das teile ich weiß nicht mehr was das
läuft der raspberry intern mit 3,3 volt oder mit 5
mit 3,3
ich glaube die gpia open sind 3,3
ein usb ist 5
können die fast 11 watt
theoretisch
da aus dem usb do aus dem usb anschluss ziehen
also maximal
so schon ganz ordentlich
3,3 ich glaube die gpia open sind 3,3
so also video display output
es gibt jetzt es gibt es micro hdmi
habe ich nur nie gehört
sieht aus wie mini usb nicht wie micro usb sieht aus wie mini usb oder
fast fast original aus wie mini usb bloß dass er gold ist
ok da braucht man einen adapter und gut ist
so was haben wir sonst noch
ethernet und usb
ok ja spätestens jetzt spätestens jetzt brauchen wir neues gehäuse
da passen die alten gräuse passen damit nicht mehr
das sieht von hinten genauso aus
die sind jetzt vertauscht
ich muss mal kurz den dreier auf den tisch stellen
die sind jetzt vertauscht beim dreier ist der ist der ich habe ich halte hier gerade daneben das seht ihr jetzt nicht
beim dreier
ist das ist die netzwerk ist der avt 45 port ist links
und beim vierer ist er rechts
deswegen können die gehäuse gar nicht mehr passen
die ausgänge sind doch woanders
kann überhaupt nicht sein dass die gehäuse passen wenn der wenn der wenn der netzwerk ausgabe auf der anderen seite ist
dass die den usb 3 gigabit direkt über pc express 2 angeschlossen haben ist endlich geil
ja das finde ich auch richtig gut
poe ok
ich muss ehrlich sagen
trotz switch und einiger netzwerk geräte die poe können
ich habe noch nie ein usb poe betrieben
ach nee die die meinen ja aber selbst mit dem poe hat ich habe hier irgendwo noch ein poe hat weil ich mir gedacht habe das bestimmt cool
aber habe ich nie verwendet
ok bla bla bla
bla bla bla genau ist jetzt über pc express 2 angeschlossen das sehr nice ist
das flutscht dann wenigstens ordentlich
new raspian software aaaah
debian buster release jawoll
oh das ist nice da freue ich mich
dass es ein neues respian gibt
das ist massive poggers
das ist nice dass es ein neues debian gibt das problem an debian ist immer dass das zeug so alt ist was dabei ist
zum beispiel wollte ich mal das jetzt können wir das wirklich machen jetzt können wir echt mal just for fun auf dem wenn der morgen da ist
mal zfs ausprobieren weil vier gigabyte ram
ist schon mal besser als eins auf jeden fall mit einem g mit einem gigabyte ram würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt was machen
zfs mag ja gerne ein bisschen ein bisschen ram haben aber mit vier kommt man da eigentlich aus das ist übrigens totales
gerücht dass zfs unglaublich viel ram braucht zfs mag ram weil es das als als
schreib buffer verwendet oder generell gerne mal als buffer verwendet aber du brauchst das nicht
du kannst zfs ohne probleme mit vier gigabyte ram oder acht gigabyte ram brauchen das zu benutzen überhaupt gar kein problem
das einzige problem was du kriegst ist wenn du de-duplication machen willst allerdings
was will eigentlich normalerweise kein de-duplication machen
und nicht live de-duplication wie das zfs macht
also quasi direkt mit riesen riesen hashtable im ram gucken
warum benutzt man debian mit so alter software eigentlich hat das nicht nachteile
ne es hat nach und es hat vorteile und nachteile ich meine das zeug was in debian raus ist funktioniert in der regel ziemlich gut
die nehmen ja nicht random irgendwelche irgendwelche versionen die nehmen ja nach möglichkeit dann
in der lts version wenn es das gibt
oder halt irgendwie dass das maintenance release bla sonst was und dazu dass das so lang da quasi abhängt
sind natürlich auch alle fehler mehr oder weniger bekannt die es gibt das ist erstmal das wichtigste
dass fehler wenigstens bekannt sind die es gibt ja und vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen workarounds oder auch
schon schon fixes drin sind also sie sind da auch recht gut auf zack dann die sachen zu portieren
also debian hat nicht umsonst den ruf dass die dass die sehr sehr stabil sind allerdings auch sehr konservativ
was die paketauswahl angeht
allerdings ist die debian paketauswahl auch schon ziemlich groß
kann man jetzt nicht mit dem archlinux vergleichen
da gibt es ja alles im endeffekt für auch wenn du auch wenn es im prinzip ja einfach nur ein repo mit passenden
bildskript ist was es im hintergrund selbst kompiliert allerdings ist die debian paketauswahl schon ziemlich groß
hoffentlich nur lesen im ram buffern
nö nö kannst mit zfs kannst auch ram schreiben
aber das ist nicht schlimm weil der extra also der managt das nicht so dass quasi
ein write ins ram gleich einem write auf zfs ist also du verlierst dann halt das was du im buffer hast
allerdings ist danach dein zfs nicht inkonsistent
also das ist für das es jetzt ein neues verspielen auf buster gibt finde ich extrem nice
der tommy schreibt nutze sein neuestem archlinux auf dem laptop die akkuleistung ist sicherlich um das dreifache gestiegen im vergleich zu windows ok das wundert mich jetzt
vielleicht läuft weniger im hintergrund
weil an sich sollte eigentlich die hardware unterstützung prinzipiell unter windows besser sein als unter archlinux
weil es was heißt die hardware unterstützung ist jetzt das falsche wort die die das das bessere ausnutzen der hardware und alle funktionen der hardware und auch alle stromsparmodi der hardware
sollte eigentlich unter windows einfacher sein und besser sein weil sie die offiziellen treiber verwenden vom hersteller und die wissen in der regel besser wie es funktioniert als jemand der das nachbaut
oder sie vor fünf jahren zuletzt ihren dienungstreiber aktualisiert haben also normalerweise ist das unter windows ein ticken besser
was natürlich sein kann ist das unter einem archlinux einfach schlicht ergreifend deutlich weniger läuft als unter windows und es deswegen länger hält
ok das ist jetzt update für raspbian das raspberry pi 4 case
ja da steht doch jetzt auch da dass man ein neues case braucht wer hat vorhin noch mal erzählt man braucht angeblich kein neues case ach ach hier
ach ach hier ja gut ja gut das funktioniert natürlich gar nicht mehr vorstellen ja ja gut man kann was abschnippeln
ja ok so schlecht sieht es doch gar nicht aus oder ich finde das ok ich meine so ist schon besser aber ich meine so wild ist es jetzt auch nicht
zumal wie gesagt wenn man das für sowas wie ein octopi oder so verwendet man hat seinen 3d drucker ja meistens eh so ein bisschen im kabuff stehen oder irgendwo anders stehen
wo habt ihr eigentlich falls ihr einen 3d drucker habt wo habt ihr eigentlich euren 3d drucker stehen ich hab den bei mir in so einer abstellkammer hier schräg gegenüber stehen
wo sonst irgendwelche vorratsdinger drin stehen so irgendwie klopapier steht da noch drin irgendwelche schraubensets und werkzeuggedöns und abstellkammer halt
ich hab mir schon überlegt ob ich den nicht vielleicht bei mir ins arbeitszimmer unter die klimaanlage stellen soll und dann die klimaanlage auf lüften stellen wenn ich den anmache kann ich mich zugucken
allerdings brauch ich das nicht weil ich hab ja jetzt habt ihr letztens im stream gesehen die kamera am raspberry kann ich anmachen mit led ring was hast du was hast du alles schon gedruckt
hauptsächlich eigentlich gehäuse für meine für meine geräte ja also ich hab hier ein paar esp 32 rumhängen und ein paar esp 282 86 da habe ich ein paar gehäuse für gedruckt
letztens haben wir für das loragateway was gedruckt jef christ das toilettenufo genau der led ring
kannst du nicht ein gehäuse für den raspberry 4 drucken doch könnte ich das lohnt sich aber interregel nicht das dauert ewig so große gehäuse zu drucken weil so groß ist der raspberry
also qualitativ ist das hier bestimmt schöner als was ich daheim aus dem 3d drucker rauskrieg aber könnte man machen ja und gibt es schon wollen wir mal gucken
explore things hat sich der drucker schon amortisiert ich finde schon ich konnte damit ein paar sachen machen die mir schon lange auf den keks gegangen sind
wirklich lohnt tut er sich natürlich nie aber gibt schon ein pie 4 case garantiert
also jetzt explizit die pie 4 case sehe ich da jetzt noch nicht wenn du aufdreh gedruckt würde es sich lohnen sollst du was machen so mehr stress als dass es was bringt
außerdem ist es meiner jetzt auch nicht der geilste 3d drucker wo einer was mit ausgedruckt haben will also pie 4 gehäuse sehe ich jetzt noch nicht aber wahrscheinlich hat ja auch kaum nur einer noch
ein pie 4 meiner wie gesagt ich dürfte einer der ersten sein der mit einer normalen bestellung einen kriegt ich meine ich habe gleich heute morgen direkt nachdem es rausgekommen ist nachdem es mir das im baro damals von morgen auf twitter geschrieben hat
habe ich mir gedacht der scheiß ist so schnell ausverkauft direkt ins shop rein direkt ins shop rein und gleich bestellt was hast du bis jetzt gedruckt 3d drucker wie gesagt hauptsächlich gehäuse für meine für meine geräte letztens haben wir im stream den hier ausgedruckt
nicht den da was ein design den haben wir ausgedruckt mit dem zäpfchen hier allerdings ohne das zäpfchen einfach nur mit dem deckel den haben wir letztens ausgedruckt da kommt folgendes rein
das da kommt da rein als lorra gateway aktuell nur p2p twitch toss warum was ist was war mit toss achso hier wegen der dildo form da ja das ist aber so dass viele gehäuse oder ganz oder oder allgemein so viele plastik
boxen sehen aus wie wie ja die schwänze so im endeffekt von kathos das sieht das sieht aus wie so ein taxi aus das fünfte element das auch jemand kennt sieht es ja auch so blatt aus ja das haben wir letztens ausgedruckt ne nicht das das andere ja und es sieht eigentlich ganz nice aus jetzt ich würde euch ja mal ein foto zeigen wenn ich eine idee hätte wie ich das ausgedruckt habe
wie ich ich mache mal ein foto von also das ist wirklich gut geworden ich muss nur mal gucken wie ich das foto euch dann schicken kann irgendwie ich will ja nicht mein mein handy anklopfen
ich habe jetzt ein follow gemacht jetzt muss man mal gucken wie man das geshared kriegt wie kriege ich das jetzt ordentlich von meinem handy geshared auf meinen streaming account das ist tatsächlich keine allzu einfache aufgabe
irgendwie könnte man das machen twitter da muss ich auf twitter posten imigur machen wir ja genau
imigur so wer in der kram hochklägt upload images
mach endlich einen discord server ja ich habe ja schon ewig ein aber da hänge ich eigentlich nur mit dem friseur und dem master clubber zusammen rum und sonst ist da keiner
ein paar videos haben wir da drin schon aufgenommen den wollte ich ja eigentlich public machen aber irgendwie habe ich bis jetzt noch nicht hingekriegt dann
ok so ich habe das bild hochgeladen und jetzt
und wo sehe ich jetzt die url aber warum ist das wieder so kompliziert gemacht ah hier imigur.com
das h3r6dg9 ja da sieht man es ja die schraube ist habe ich die schraube richtig reingedreht das ist das einzige aber das ist doch ganz nice
mit dem mit dem display die neben blinks rot werden gps daten vorhanden sind das ist das ist nicht fancy steckdose das ist also das ding hängt
halt neben an der steckdose dran die die steckdose hat damit nichts zu tun aber die steckdose ist tatsächlich richtig gut
das ist eine seawave steckdose mit strom also kann ich kann stromverbrauch messen und du kannst das licht unter abhängig davon man kann das licht unter konfigurieren wie es sein soll
und zeug und hat einen ausschalter und zwei usb anschlüsse bis 5 volt 2,4 ampere also die steckdosen sind wirklich gut und sind nicht sonderlich teuer
die ist ja auch geflasht nein die ist nicht geflasht die ist aber seawave und seawave ist quasi per protokollspezifikation für alle offen
lgb steckdose war geil die ist wirklich gut die steckdose wir können ja nochmal ein reflink generieren wo wir gerade dabei sind warum lande ich immer auf diesem kack handyhalter hier eigentlich
die steckdose hier die da allerdings kauft ihr nicht bei amazon ich generiere auch kein reflink weil die sind viel zu teuer auf amazon die sind viel zu teuer auf amazon
also wenn ihr das ding sucht wenn ihr das ding sucht dann guckt mal bei irgendeinem anderen bei notebooks notebooks billiger gab sie letztens 35 prozent günstiger für paar und zwanzig
die haben die hier nicht mehr haben die hier nicht mehr
die haben die anscheinend nicht mehr doch hä guck der kostet nämlich nur 29 und das ist ein preis dafür kann man die sich kaufen die war letztens im angebot noch ein bisschen billiger aber 29 euro ist wirklich ein ganz fairer preis dafür
ne das ist glaube ich noch nicht mal eine china steckdose unter der haube wahrscheinlich dem was drinnen ist ist bestimmt eine china steckdose aber also wenn man ein z-wave netzwerk daheim hat ist das finde ich aktuell die beste steckdose die es gibt
z-wave steckdosen braucht man ein paar z-wave dazu dass man das netzwerk quasi ausbreiten kann z-wave ist quasi mesh basiert also sprich mit jedem gerät erweitert man das netzwerk weil die untereinander reden und allerdings nur geräte die angeschlossen sind am strom können das z-wave netz quasi als relay erweitern
deswegen habe ich quasi in paar räumen inklusive im keller so eine z-wave steckdose hier aber die ist echt praktisch du kannst jetzt kann den stromverbrauch messen du hast zwei usb anschlüsse ordentlich die dir auch für quickcharge eignen du hast einen anderen ausschalter und du kannst das licht konfigurieren das kann man zum beispiel auch als nacht licht verwenden
bei mir ist zum beispiel neben dem klo hängt noch eine da ist da war mal ein tablet dran das hängt da immer noch aber ist nicht mehr an ist das zigbee nein das ist z-wave das ist was anderes
und ich habe sie so eingestellt dass die nachts halt auch wenn der eigentliche strom aus ist leuchtet sie bei mir nachts und so sehe ich ob die tür zum klo auf oder zu ist weil ich habe schon geschafft gegen die tür zu rennen nachts wenn sie zu war und es ist halt ich weiß wenn es halt sagt dunkel ist siehst du nicht dass die tür zu ist und denkst du passt schon
beim ich ich habe nur die hier ich finde die kombination mit usb stecker auch gerade gut weil im endeffekt die chancen dass man mal dort wo die steckdose ist aber kurz über kurz oder lang usb braucht ist habe ich jetzt am eigenen leib gespürt relativ hoch im keller zum beispiel ist es so da hängt ja auch so eine und im keller ist einmal den raspberry zero dran
an dem usb anschluss war auch so eine stelle wo ich eigentlich früher nicht gedacht habe dass ich da einen usb anschluss brauche
da ist ein raspberry zero dran am usb anschluss und hier an der eigentlichen steckdose ist der andere kram dran für stromversorgung von den tablets im flur und der esp 32 der an den beiden stromzählern hängt
auf dem schall am schall ganz genau ich dachte dort wo es dort die steckdose ist die chancen dass man mal ein usb anschluss haben will ist gar nicht so klein
Außerdem, was du dann machen könntest ist, also geht jetzt an den Eichler, was du machen
könntest ist, du könntest zum Beispiel dort einen ESP8266 mit Rüttelsensor hinhängen,
da könntest du genau sagen, wann die Waschmaschine voraussichtlich fertig ist, wenn du mal das
Waschprogramm analysiert hast. Ist das nicht nice? Also kannst du dann quasi messen, wie
sehr die Waschmaschine rüttelt und dann kannst du daran feststellen, wie lange sie noch braucht
oder ob sie noch an ist. Du kannst natürlich auch einfach den Stromverbrauch messen hier
mit, das ist aber die Noob-Variante. Oder du guckst einfach auf die Anzeige der Waschmaschine.
Ja, das ist aber nur möglich, wenn du davor stehst. Wenn du jetzt beispielsweise sagen
willst, ah gut, ich guck mal kurz in meinem Dashboard nach, wann die Wäsche fertig ist,
dann kann ich das nicht. Hast du von einem Hack von Philips Hue Lampen gehört? Die haben
eine Lampe dazu gebracht, andere zu infizieren, dann könnten sich auch andere Städte ausbreiten.
Nein, habe ich nichts von gehört, allerdings sind wir da wieder beim Thema. Wenn man eben
herstellergebundene Sachen einsetzt, dann kann einem sowas passieren. Okay, nee, das stimmt
nicht. Das kann dir mit allem theoretisch passieren. Allerdings, wenn du geschlossene Systeme
einsetzt, hast du im Prinzip keine Chance. Dann merkst du oftmals die Sache, wenn es
zu spät ist und du kannst halt auch nichts dran ändern. Deswegen, sofern es sich um
WLAN handelt, alles in eigenem Netz packen und gut ist. Nee, aber da habe ich nichts
von gehört. Bis vor zwei Wochen schreibt der Sunset, hätte er nicht gedacht, dass
er 27 Raspberry Pies in seiner Wohnung braucht. Hast du da irgendwie einen Rendercluster oder
was hast du da mit 27 Raspberry Pies? War über ZigBee, ja. Ja, das ist das, was wir
letztens im Stream ausgedruckt haben. Also man sieht, das hat prinzipiell funktioniert.
Und außer, dass ich die Schraube noch nicht ganz reingedreht habe, was aber Absicht ist,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, vielleicht will ich es noch mal aufmachen und noch mal vielleicht
eine andere Antenne oder so, bevor ich es unter das Dach stelle, ist das mit dem 3D-Drucker
ganz praktisch. Und das ist eigentlich die hauptsächliche Sache, die ich bisher ausgedruckt
habe mit dem 3D-Drucker. Gehäuse für meinen Technikkram. Das einzige, was ich mal ausgedruckt
habe, ist noch eine Maus für die Katze. Die interessiert sie aber nicht. Aber gut, was
soll meine Katze auf so eine scheiß Plastikmaus interessieren, ja. Overwatch in the nutshell,
please. Ja, mach mal, mach mal gleich, mach mal gleich. Ja, was gab es denn jetzt noch
zum Raspberry zu sagen? Wir haben eigentlich mehr oder weniger die Sachen durch. Ich wollte
noch mal kurz gucken, was Heise dazu geschrieben hat. Also ich freue mich wirklich darauf,
dass das Ding morgen ankommt und ich bin mal gespannt, was das an Leistung bringt. Wir
gucken jetzt noch mal kurz, was Heise dazu geschrieben hat, ob die noch irgendwelche,
nur mal kurz überfliegen, ob die noch irgendwelche Details drin hatten, die wir jetzt nicht
gesehen haben. Doppelte HDMI, USB-C, haben wir schon festgestellt. 32-Spit-Respian, aber
war mir im Endeffekt klar, dass das kein 64-Spit, also die CPUs können 64-Spit, allerdings
aus Abwehrskompatibilitätsgründen ist Respian 32-Spit, das wundert mich nicht. 4K-Video
haben wir auch, Leistungsaufnahme, das ist vielleicht noch ganz interessant. Leerlauf
4,4 Watt, das ist mehr als der alte auf jeden Fall. Ach so, Maus Gigabit-Verbindung, aber
es ist auf jeden Fall mehr als der alte. Genau, Pi 3 Model B Plus braucht 3,1 Watt, 2,5 Watt
ohne. Ja, das kann ich ungefähr bestätigen. Es hält sich aber in Grenzen. Unterlast maximal
7,6, was nicht viel mehr ist. Ja, das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen. Miniserver, ja,
das werden wir morgen ausprobieren. Beeindruckendes Upgrade. Könnte ich auch so unterschreiben
von dem, was ich jetzt gelesen habe? Also, die Entwicklung finde ich wirklich gut, da
es nichts grundlegend bahnbrechend Neues ist, war ja klar, weil ich meine, die leben davon,
dass das Raspberry Pi Ökosystem etabliert ist. Wenn die jetzt quasi die Rückwärtskompatibilität
brechen würden, das wäre ja der Fail des Jahres, des Jahrzehnts von denen. Quasi das,
was sie sich über 10 Jahre oder so aufgebaut haben, ich weiß gar nicht, wann der erste
Raspberry Pi rausgekommen ist. Ähm, quasi mit nicht rückwärtskompatiblem Jahr. Okay,
sieben Jahre. Ne, mit sieben und halb Jahre. Nicht rückwärtskompatiblem, ähm, Dings
nicht zu versauen, das war klar. Wo kann man den Quellcode von einem Projekt finden?
Bei mir auf GitHub. Da gibt es allerdings nicht so viel, weil ich die meisten Sachen
nicht hoch gelernt habe oder die neueren Versionen noch nicht hoch gelernt habe. Aber das, was
es gibt, gibt es da. Der erste Pi war nicht abwärtskompatibel, ja ach. Das ist ja mal
absolut Big Brain. So, okay Leute, ähm, der Tommy will die ganze Zeit schon, dass wir
uns ein Video angucken, was sich nennt, ähm, wo ist es denn überhaupt? Tommy findet das
Video nicht. Ach, da. Also, das ist wahrscheinlich ein, äh, ne, äh, Tommy, was du mir geschickt
hast, ist ein League of Legends Video. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht das Overwatch Video.
League of Legends Videos müssen wir uns nicht angucken, da habe ich absolut keinen Plan
davon. Jo, ich auch nicht. Ach, hier. Okay, monoton und unfähig. Volume 1, Genji Overwatch.
Okay, und was ist das für ein Video? Warum sollen wir uns das angucken? Äh, ist das
irgendwie so ein, so ein, äh, Video zum Status von, zum aktuellen Status von Overwatch oder
wie, oder was, oder wo? Redet einfach über OW. Naja, weiß nicht, ob wir das jetzt gucken.
Ich komme mal kurz rein. Oh, eine Donation. Also, ich habe gerade mal reingeschaut, das
gucke ich mir nach dem Stream an. Ich glaube, das ist nichts für, für, für Onstream. Wobei
ich mir überlegt habe, wir können uns durchaus die anderen aktuellen Videos mal angucken,
äh, zu Themen, die gerade angesagt sind. Der Pavillon, ne, ne, ne, Rammstein, das, ich
fand das so schlecht, äh, auch die, auch die anderen neuen Sachen irgendwie. Also Rammstein
ist ja generell nicht mein, mein, mein Fall. Genau, Reaction Content, ja, das hat uns noch
gefehlt. Vor allem natürlich bei mir im Stream am besten ohne Facecam, ohne alles. Ja, ich
habe, ich habe das, das, Seagull hatte mal ein Video gemacht zum Thema Status von Overwatch
und der Sache konnte ich eigentlich nur zustimmen. Ich gucke es mir nachher an, ja. Kurz gesagt
Videos anschauen, ja, die sind gut. Es war ja auch wieder Bild 2019, da muss ich noch
ein paar Videos nachholen, allerdings ist es nichts, was wir uns im Stream angucken können,
weil so ein Konferenztalk, der geht halt ne Stunde. Joa, aber ich bin mal gespannt drauf,
wann der Raspberry morgens ankommt. Wo war die da? Bluetooth Shell. Dönsr. Bin ja auch
nicht mehr zufrieden mit Heise irgendwie, ne. Ich habe ja seit Ewig, Ewigkeit, also
wirklich lange, 10 Jahre oder 15, Ewig, ja, CT abonniert und mittlerweile ist es so,
dass ich vielleicht im Jahr mal 3, 4 Artikel lese. Also das hat, das lohnt sich irgendwie
nicht mehr. Eigentlich, eigentlich war ich bisher nur zu faul das Ganze abzubestellen.
Die CT ist ja, ja, was heißt, du kommst nicht in der, man muss sie ja eigentlich auch gar
nicht, es steht ja auch nichts interessantes drin zum größten Teil, das ist ja das Problem.
Und Heise, ich gucke mir jeden Tag immer im Zug so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Heise
an News, aber irgendwie sind auch viele Artikel, das, was ich quasi erwarten würde von einer
News Seite, steht offenbar gar nicht drinne. Ja, letztens, letztens gab es zum Beispiel
die Sacklücke. Kennt ihr die Sacklücke? Ja die, Sack, der TCP Sack. Also da gab es
letztens, gab es eine Sicherheitslücke, da konntest du quasi mit, wie war das, mit
manipulierten, mit manipulierten Paketen konntest du irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass quasi der,
der, der Buffer, wo irgendwie die, die TCP Acknowledge Geschichten drinne gespeichert
werden irgendwie overflowed. Da konntest du die Server abschießen. Gab es letztens eine
Sacklücke. So und im Prinzip hat Heise es noch nicht mal geschafft, also sie haben einfach
nur geschrieben, es gibt jetzt die Sacklücke und haben einen Link zum Red Hat Bug Tracker
reingemacht, wo ich mal zumindest erwartet hätte, dass man vielleicht noch 2, 3 Informationen
dazu kriegt, was sich dahinter verbirgt. Weil ansonsten muss ich das auch nicht auf Heise
lesen, ansonsten kann ich das auch selbst im Bug Tracker lesen. Bin gerade reingekommen,
für was ist der Raspberry Pi? Der Raspberry Pi ist aktuell noch gar nicht, der Raspberry
Pi kommt erst morgen. Wir haben uns gerade nur die neuesten Specks vom Raspberry Pi 4
angeguckt und sind eigentlich so einstimmig der Meinung, das macht einen ziemlich guten
Eindruck und morgen kommt er dann an und morgen machen wir ein paar Benchmarks und probieren
mal wie schnell die Netzwerkübertragung ist, inklusive verschlüsselter Platte und wie
schnell die vor allem übersammbar ist, sequenziell und ein bisschen random. Probieren wir morgen
aus. Ja das ist halt der Standardbehalte. Ich lese das nicht mehr gerne. Was kann ich
damit machen? Du meinst mit einem Raspberry Pi? Naja da läuft ein vollständiges Devi-
Anlienungs drauf, also du kannst damit erstmal alles das machen, was du unter einem Devi-
Anlienungs so machen kannst. Also vielleicht möchtest du mal Nextcloud bei dir daheim
hosten oder einen Minecraft Server bei dir daheim hosten oder im Bereich Heimautomatisierung
Dinge machen, wo du halt ne Kiste brauchst, die nicht viel Strom verbraucht und den ganzen
Tag halt an ist, den ganzen Tag und ne gewisse Leistung hat, weil sag mal so Sachen die den
ganzen Tag an sind, da würde ich eher einen ESP32 oder sowas nehmen, wenn nicht Kleinkran
so als Sensor. Ja wenn du ein vollständiges Server Betriebssystem brauchst auf einer
Plattform, die schnell genug ist und wenig Strom verbraucht. Was gibt es denn für gute
Alternativen für Heise? Also ich gucke eigentlich immer noch ganz gerne Golem, da würde ich
nicht sagen, dass das wirklich viel besser ist. Die beste Alternative zu Heise und generell
Computerzeug ist Reddit und Twitter, aber hauptsächlich Reddit. Also die Kombination
mit mit Twitter und Reddit, da bist du eigentlich immer ganz gut informiert. Na gut Reddit muss
man ja auch nicht haben, das kann man ja auch lesen. Was hältst du von Fefe? Hat mich
Nikrosadi angesprochen. Ich glaube Fefe ist RL ein sehr anstrengender Typ, wenn man das
so liest. Nee hat mich Nikrosadi angesprochen, die Posts. Achja genau, Happy Enter hat vollkommen
recht, Hacker News natürlich auch und natürlich PC Welt. Ja aber Hacker News ist auch immer
gut, wenn man es liest hier. Dafür hat man auch immer interessante Sachen und das schöne
auf Hacker News ist sogar noch mehr, guck mal da haben wir doch hier gerade schon die
schöne Frage, was macht ihr mit eurem Raspberry? Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, weil da war
doch gerade die Frage, was kann man damit machen. Das schöne auf Hacker News ist, noch
mehr als auf Reddit, dass da viele Leute lesen, die quasi um dies geht. Also zum Beispiel
wenn es irgendwie eine News Post gibt, so nach dem, ja Google hat jetzt mal wieder irgendwie
ein neues Android, kann es durchaus sein, dass hier auch mal ein Android Entwickler
was schreibt und sowas. Das ist sogar eher die Regel als die Ausnahme, dass Leute um
die die News geht, was da zu schreiben. Also das ist wirklich sehr schön. Die Seite, ich
gebe zu die Seite, sieht scheiße aus im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Seiten heute, aber sie funktioniert.
Und wisst ihr was ich sehr gut finde? Sie hat kein Endless Scroll. Ich hasse Endless
Scroll. Endless Scroll ist der größte Crap überhaupt. Ich meine das ist jetzt nicht
viel besser als Endless Scroll. Ich mag wenn Seiten Pages haben. Dass man sagen kann, ok
ich habe 500 Seiten Kommentare und ich kann mich noch ungefähr dran erinnern, aha ja
so ich hab mal da vor zwei Monaten reingeguckt auf Seite 43, da war was. Du hast YouTube gar
keine Chance mehr, Comments in der richtigen Reihenfolge zu lesen, weil es Endless Scroll
ist und keine Pages mehr hat. Totaler Crap. Ja also wir hatten vorhin noch ein paar interessante
Fragen, gucken ob ich da noch drauf eingehen kann. Als erstes gucken wir uns aber noch
mal an, was die Leute denn mit ihrem Raspberry machen. Was ich damit mache, habe ich jetzt
ja schon erzählt. Stimmt die NASA wurde angeblich, ja ich weiß, habt ihr das gelesen, die NASA
wurde angeblich über den Raspberry Pi gehackt. Allerdings ist die Sache, dass es ein Raspberry
Pi war, eher zweitrangig. Die Frage ist eher, warum hängt das Ding einfach im Netz ungesichert
und ohne Kontrolle rum. Das ist die eigentliche Frage, weil es hätte kein Raspberry sein
müssen, es hätte wahrscheinlich jeder andere Laptop auch sein können. Aber ich glaube
nicht, nichts Schlimmes passiert, da haben sie über irgendeine Mars Mission irgendwas
abgezogen. Also für was verwenden die Leute denn so ihren Raspberry? Er verwende das
irgendwie in seinem Auto, ok quasi als Media Center im Auto verwende der das, ok. Auf
die Idee wäre ich jetzt noch nicht gekommen. Raspberry Pi Home Assistant, Z-Wave Dongle,
habe ich am Anfang auch gemacht, ist allerdings für Home Assistant ätzend langsam. Octoprint,
jawoll, mache ich auch auf einem Raspberry. Der einzige Fullsize Raspberry, den ich aktuell
verwende ist für Octo, Octo Pi. FullPageOS, kenne ich nicht. Ist es anscheinend quasi
ein Raspbian Fork, wahrscheinlich ein Raspbian Install Script, was einen Fullscreen Chrome
im Kiosk Modus startet. Ja das ist ganz nützlich, wenn man keine Android Tablets benutzen will
an die Wand, sondern einen Raspberry an die Wand hängen will mit Bildschirm. Das funktioniert
aber bloß bei den Amis gut, weil die Amis haben Holzwände. Bei uns ist ein Raspberry
mit Touch Bildschirm zu dick. Ein Raspberry mit Touch Bildschirm davor, das ist mal locker
5-6 cm, der guckt einfach zu weit von der Wand raus. Bei den Amis ist das kein Problem,
die haben Holzwände, die schneiden einfach ein Loch rein und der Raspberry verschwindet
in der Wand und es hängt bloß noch das Display dran. Ich finde die Umbauanleitung immer geil,
wenn irgendwie einer postet im Forum und das erste was du siehst ist wie er erstmal
mit das Segelloch in die Wand schneidet. Dann denke ich mir auch immer, ok, nächste Anleitung
funktioniert bei mir nicht. Aber sind Tablets sich relativ teuer, das richtig. Allerdings
ein Raspberry plus Bildschirm kostet auch nicht wenig. Warum gehe ich bei Amazon immer
auf diesen komischen Handyhalter? Was juckt mich denn dieser komische Handyhalter? Das
passt noch nicht mal für mein iPhone. Du kannst dir aber auch einfach ein Fire 8 kaufen
für 89 Euro oder 50 Euro oder 40 Euro, was es an Weihnachten immer kostet und das Flash
dann dann einfach. Ich war es den Flashen nicht, ich habe gesehen es gibt jetzt das
erste experimentelle Rom. Flashen ist das falsche Wort, du machst nur einen Launcher
drauf und machst den Amazon Crap weg. Das dürfte dann vom Preis sehr unschlagbar als
Dashboard sein. Für das Dashboard habe ich mir einen Fire HD10 gekauft, zwei Stück letztes
Jahr. Die habe ich auch geroutet und einen anderen Launcher drauf gemacht. Dann ist halt
das Amazon Zeug weg. Ich habe es auch alles getrennt von meinem Amazon Account, das heißt
es kann mir jetzt auch gar nichts mehr anzeigen und verwende ich jetzt als Dashboard Tablets
im Flur an der Wand. Hast du immer noch das iPhone 6? Ja. Also sie sind bei mir auf der
Arbeit gerade dabei neue iPhones zu verteilen, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass zuerst die,
die lange keins mehr bekommen haben eins kriegen und die wo das kaputt ist. Und außerdem bin
ich gar nicht so scharf drauf, ich habe mich jetzt so sehr an meinen Home Button geklicke
gewöhnt. Mit dem neuen iPhone habe ich ja dann keinen Home Button mehr und außerdem
ist es größer. Das ist eigentlich das, was ich am wenigsten will. Ich will eigentlich
kein größeres iPhone. Ich kann das 6er kaum mit einem Finger noch richtig bedienen und
bei dem neuen mal gucken. Aber über kurz oder lang muss ich wahrscheinlich dann ein
Zehner oder was auch immer das dann ist benutzen. Okay, das klingt jetzt für einige voll abgehoben
oder so nach dem Motto, oh der arme Max, der muss ein iPhone 10 verwenden, oh der hier ist aber ganz schlecht dran und das ist kein Zehner, was ist denn das dann?
Ein Xer oder was ist das neue? Ach ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich bin mit dem 6er ganz zufrieden
und von der Geschwindigkeit her ist auch überhaupt kein Problem. Okay, was machen sonst noch
wir Messperi? Der Rest ist wieder Magic Mirror. Das habe ich mir mal angeguckt, finde ich komplett
useless. Da hat ein Typ eine Glasscheibe gebaut und mit einer Glasscheibe einen Spiegel gebaut
und hat hinter der Wand, also hinter dem Glas, hat er in den Hochkant einen LCD Monitor
noch reingebaut, dass man quasi so hatmäßig auf dem Spiegel was anzeigen kann. Finde ich
komplett useless, weil ich meine ein Spiegel, das ist was, da guckst du, also wenn jetzt
nicht gerade Grill beim Schminken bist oder so, so in so ein ganz Körperspiegel, da guckst
du am Tag 15 Sekunden rein, wenn es hochkommt, also ich zumindest. Ich gucke hauptsächlich
in den Spiegel im Bad, der ist also auf Kopfhöhe und den kann ich nicht umbauen und so ein
Ganzkörperspiegel, da steht unten im Flur ein und ob ich da jetzt den Magic Mirror draus
mache, das ist komplett useless. Ich hatte es mir mal angeguckt, aber es lohnt sich bei
mir überhaupt nicht. Ob hier Grills im Chat sind, ich gehe davon aus, nachdem was ja hier
schon die Nischen-IT-Themen sind, ich glaube da spricht weibliche Zuschauer nicht so sehr
an. Ich weiß, ich fände es cool, wenn die ein oder anderen Mädels zugucken, weil es
gibt ja auch immer mehr in der IT, die sich dafür interessieren. Warum nicht, fände
ich ganz gut. Ich habe ja angeblich auf YouTube auch 8% oder so weibliche Zuschauer, weiß
nicht ob das Fake-Accounts sind, aber mein YouTube Content ist dann zumindest noch ein
Ticken mehr, wo sich wahrscheinlich Mädels für interessieren könnten, als hier für
irgendwelche Raspberry-Pie-Geschichten. Es gibt im Inhalt keine Frauen, ja das habe
ich auch schon gehört, ja. Hast du weibliche Kolleginnen auf der Arbeit? Ja, aber nicht
viele. Wir haben zwei Datenbank-Administratorinnen, die eine kennt sich ziemlich gut aus, die
andere hat gar keinen Plan. Das ist schön im Internet, da kann man das sagen, ist vor
allem so ohne Namen, gell. Und wen haben wir sonst noch? Bei den iOS-Leuten gibt es erstaunlich
viele Mädels. Also insgesamt im Gebäude haben wir natürlich viele Mädels, da sitzt
ja alles mögliche, einfach so im MRT-Bereich. Wir haben noch, wir haben noch eine Cobol-Programmiererin.
Da habe ich gesagt, fuck, ja. Die ist so alt wie ich und hat gesagt in ihrer Ausbildung,
ich möchte Cobol lernen. Auch gut, hat anscheinend funktioniert, sie hat jetzt einen sicheren
Job. Cobolt, genau. Das ist eine schöne in der Präsentation von Cobol. Cobolt. Die
haben sogar mehr als einen Cobol-Entwickler, ich glaube wir haben drei Cobol-Entwickler
oder so. Die müssen sich um alles IBM-Zeug kümmern. Was zum Teufel ist eine Drip Irrigation?
Ist das sowas wie, dass ein Garagentor so per Neigung auf und zu machen kann? Ich habe
keine Ahnung was das sein soll. Ich suche jetzt auch nicht danach, weil das klingt irgendwie
pervers. Drip Irrigation. Warst du nicht DevOps oder so? Ja doch, mach mal Ausrufezeichen
Beruf. Max arbeitet beim Dezix. Ja, aus, da fällt mir jetzt gerade ein. Ich hatte ja
mal zu Weihnachten gesagt, letztes Jahr rum, oder Anfang Dezember letztes Jahres, dass
ich quasi ab diesem Jahr offen bin für neue Jobs. Da gab es ja tatsächlich auch ein paar
Sachen per Mail. Unter anderem hat jemand vom Dezix geschrieben, dass ich halt auch noch
Leute suche. Aber ich habe mich da noch nicht darum gekümmert. Ich habe euch ja schon mal
erzählt, ich bin ultra faul was sowas angeht. Ja gut, das hier ist natürlich massiv oversized.
Ein Raspberry Pi, der irgendeinen DNS-Skript laufen lässt. Dafür würde ich mir keinen
Raspberry hinstellen, das ist viel zu heftig. Ein DNS-Skript, paar Zeilen Bash, wozu braucht
man da einen Raspberry Pi? Dafür, also für das was man braucht, um drei Zeilen Skript
auszuführen, ist ein Raspberry Pi ja quasi schon fast wie der Supercomputer vom Wetterdienst.
Stimmt, warum geht Ausrufezeichen Beruf nicht? Doch, er hat doch oben schon geantwortet. Ausrufezeichen
Beruf geht wahrscheinlich nur alle paar Minuten mal, dass man es nicht spammen kann. Ein
Raspberry Pi reicht für OpenVPN Server in das Intranet locker. Dafür wäre zum Beispiel
jetzt der Vierer gar nicht mal so verkehrt. Bei OpenVPN profitierst du auf jeden Fall
davon, dass du eine schnellere Netzwerkkarte hast und profitierst aber auf jeden Fall davon,
dass er schneller ist. Also für einen OpenVPN Server ist tatsächlich ein Vierer keine schlechte
Idee. Vor allem, wenn es mit mehreren Benutzern benutzt wird, dann ist ein Vierer wirklich
sinnvoll. Wir haben uns doch gerade überlegt, für was ein Vierer viel besser wäre als ein
Dreier. Für eine OpenVPN Server, der vielleicht von mehr als einem Benutzern verwendet wird
und auch der Anschluss ein bisschen ab und down Bandbreite hat, dafür wäre ein Vierer
nicht verkehrt. OpenVPN nutzt aber nur einen Core. Ja, aber pro Benutzer. Ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen, dass OpenVPN alle Nutzer nur auf einem Kern macht. Warum soll es das
machen? Der forkt wahrscheinlich für... Ich habe schon lange kein OpenVPN mehr von Hand
eingerichtet. Jahre nicht mehr. Und IPsec von Hand noch nie. Also Server. Es gibt jetzt
ein neues VPN, was ich mal ausprobieren wollte. Wie hieß das denn? Ist gerade voll angesagt.
Wie hieß das denn? Das ist gerade voll modern. Wireguard? Kann das Wireguard sein?
War das Wireguard? Gab es sich auch was wie ZeroVPN oder so? Das ist wieder was anderes,
ne? Ne, ne, das ist was anderes. Ich glaube Wireguard war das, was ich mal ausprobieren
wollte. Was angeblich jetzt schon eine deutlich bessere Android App hat als OpenVPN und halt
auch Open Source ist. Ja, doch ich glaube Wireguard ist das. Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Aber einfach nur ausprobieren. Ich brauche aktuell kein VPN. Heim. Da keinen Bedarf
für gerade. Nachdem ich jetzt ja mein Positions-Tracking über MQTT mache mit einem Server im Internet,
brauche ich kein VPN mehr. Was ist MQTT? Das ist ein Message-Q. Also das ist im Prinzip,
wie kann man das am besten erklären? Wahrscheinlich mit einem Bild. Ja, das Bild ist eigentlich
ganz gut. MQTT ist ein sehr leichtgewichtiger, also in Form von dass halt die Nachrichten
selbst weitmäßig ziemlich klein sind, sehr leichtgewichtige Message-Q. Das funktioniert
folgendermaßen, du hast einen MQTT-Server und da gibt es verschiedene Topics drauf.
Ein Topic ist ein Titel halt. Kannst du nennen, wie du willst. Du kannst ein Topic beispielsweise
machen für alle möglichen Themen, die du brauchst. So irgendwie keine Ahnung. Machst
ein eigenes Topic für Haustür, ein eigenes Topic für Zugverspätung, ein eigenes Topic
für Garagentor oder so. Und dann kannst du dich mit dem jeweiligen Client subscriben
zu so einem Topic oder publishen zu so einem Topic, was nichts anderes heißt, wie du kannst
quasi dort Daten reinschieben in dieses Topic oder eben informiert werden, wenn neue Daten
reingeschoben worden. Also praktisch, bei mir funktioniert das so. Ich habe auf meinem
iPhone eine App, die regelmäßig meine Position abruft per GPS und die publisht das dann an
einem MQTT-Broker im Internet. Das Ganze ist SSL verschlüsselt und Passwort geschützt.
Das heißt, das kann auch keiner mithören und meine Heimautomatisierungslösung ist
subscribt zu diesem MQTT-Broker im Internet. Das bedeutet, sobald mein iPhone quasi den
neuen Standort publisht, ein bisschen mehr ist bei mir noch dazwischen, allerdings genauso
wie ich es erkläre, wird es auch funktionieren, bekommt es meine Heimautomatisierung mit und
dann kann ich darauf reagieren. Man benutzt hauptsächlich im Heimautomatisierungsbereich
oder generell auch im weiteren Sinne, auch im Embedded-Bereich zum Kommunizieren, weil
es einfach ein sehr kompaktes Protokoll ist. Deutlich kompakter, als wenn du es jetzt
bei HTTP irgendwo hinschickst oder so. Also so ein HTTP-Request ist huge, also ist massive
gegenüber einem MQTT-Publish. Ein MQTT-Publish sind im Prinzip die Daten, die du publishen
willst, zum Beispiel Hoftour ist jetzt auf, ein Topic dazu und ganz, ganz wenige Bites
drumherum. Das geht sau schnell und ist sehr, sehr leichtgewichtig, da hingegen ist ein
HTTP-Request massiv viel. Wieso guckst du nicht einfach, ob in deinem Netzwerk gerade
ein Device mit deiner MAC-Adresse deines iPhones angemeldet ist? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Kann man gucken, ob ich was übersehen habe oben. Ich will jetzt auch der Frage nicht
ausweichen, weil es hat einen guten Grund. Genau, warum ich nicht einfach gucke, warum
die MAC von meinem iPhone im Netzwerk hängt, ist ganz einfach. Ich gucke schon, ob die
MAC von meinem iPhone im Netzwerk hängt und sollte das der Fall sein, wird in meiner Heim-Automatisierungslösung
automatisch, egal was alle anderen Sensoren sagen, meinen Zustand auf Zuhause geändert.
Max Electronics hat schon ein bisschen Recht, also bei einem ESP32 hast du deutlich genug
RAM für den HTTP-Request, allerdings ist der HTTP-Request teilweise so groß, was du
deinem Header noch alles brauchst, dass du das von einem Controller gar nicht schicken
kannst. Ich brauche die Positionsdaten unterwegs, nicht dass ich weiß, ob ich daheim bin, sondern
ich brauche es, dass ich weiß, dass ich, wenn ich nicht daheim bin, wo ich bin, dass
ich dann feststellen kann, ob ich mich in einer gewissen Entfernung zu Zuhause befinde
und ob meine Richtung gerade ist, ich bewege mich auf Zuhause zu oder von Zuhause weg.
Das heißt, ich kann zum Beispiel dadurch, dass ich meine Positionsdaten übertrage,
bei mir als hier über MQTT, in mein Heim-Automatisierungssystem, kann ich zum Beispiel eine Automatisierung
machen wie, es ist Außentemperatur von über 30 Grad, der Max befindet sich gerade auf
dem Heimweg, weil meine Travel Direction eben Richtung Home ist und bei der aktuellen
Geschwindigkeit wird er wahrscheinlich in ungefähr 15 Minuten daheim sein und wenn
er innerhalb von 5 Minuten Heimweg ist, dann mache ich schon mal die Klimaanlage im Arbeitszimmer
an. So was könnte man zum Beispiel damit machen.
Außerdem ist es ganz schön, wenn man sich in seiner Heimautomatisierung drauf nicht
nur auf einen Sensor verlässt, was Presence Detection angeht, also das Ganze nennt sich
ja Presence Detection, wenn man einfach gucken will, wer wo wann gerade ist, weil so ein
Sensor fehlt öfters und gerade das iPhone ist bekannt dafür, sich abzuschalten zwischendurch,
sprich, wenn ihr mal ein iPhone pingt, dann wird das iPhone immer mal wieder minutenlang
nicht antworten und dann mal wieder 10 Sekunden antworten. Das heißt so ein reiner Ping-Test
oder sonst was ist mit einem iPhone nicht so einfach. Also am besten ist man kombiniert
das. Ich kombiniere das mit MQTT, ich kombiniere das mit meinem Access Point und mit Bluetooth
Erkennung und wenn eins davon sagt, ich bin zu Hause, dann bin ich auch wirklich da.
Ein Sensor allein ist oftmals nicht zuverlässig genug. Man macht so mal wieder einen Gartenstelz,
dazu muss es erstmal schneien. Was nutzt du als Heimautomatisierung? Also als Dashboard
und als Hub verwende ich Home Assistant. Ich nehme mal an, für den Pi 4 Talk muss
ich Wort gucken. Wir haben uns die Sachen jetzt schon mehr oder weniger angeguckt, wenn
es noch offene Sachen gibt. Wie gesagt, der ganze Stream ist, heißt ja nicht umsonst Raspberry
Pi 4 Hype. Morgen kommt er an. Wir haben uns auch schon aufgeschrieben, was wir testen
werden morgen. Und das heißt ich bin morgen auch wieder am Start. Hallo Rainer GWF. Die
Leute die GPS ausschalten? Keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich ja. Ich habe Location Tracking auch nicht für
alle Apps erlaubt. Allerdings so Sachen wie Navigationsdings ist halt schlecht, wenn du
den Zugriff auf GPS nicht erlaubst. Kannst du die Stromspargeschichte für WLAN im iPhone
nicht abschalten? Vielleicht, aber will ich gar nicht, weil dann brauchst du mehr Strom.
Ja cheat, können wir machen. Oder werden wir wahrscheinlich mit unseren Tests eh machen.
Das finde ich tatsächlich eine sinnvolle Regelung, dass man auf dem iPhone Apps einstellen kann
die Berechtigung nur gelten, nur wenn sie auch läuft. Wobei, auf der anderen Seite ist
es ja beim iPhone so, Hintergrund Apps sind ja faktisch kaum möglich beim iPhone. Du
wirst auf dem iPhone eh, also wenn du eine App hast, die irgendwie eine Händlschleife
laufen hat, die irgendwas macht, du wirst hart abgeschossen nach 10 Minuten oder 6 Minuten.
Kannst du mir nicht merken, aber es ist Apple Policy. Also du darfst deine App gar nicht
im Hintergrund laufen lassen. Du darfst dich zu gewissen Diensten subscriben, zum Beispiel
Location Changed oder sowas in der Richtung und kannst dann auch sagen, ja ich möchte
mich anmelden dafür, dass, also mit deiner App, ich will da quasi Hintergrunddienste
nutzen, dann kriegst du dann irgendwie alle 10 Sekunden mal eine halbe Sekunde CPU Zeit
und sowas. Allerdings wirklich im Hintergrund laufen lassen wie eine Android geht ja unter
iOS gar nicht. Unter iOS 13 kannst du Shortcuts automatisch laufen. Da hab ich so meine Zweifel,
dass das funktioniert, weil Apple, also die wichtigste Apple Policy, die sie immer hatten,
ist, Sachen dürfen nur durch User Interaktion gestartet werden und das war bei Shortcuts
immer so. Deswegen konntest du nie sagen, keine Ahnung, es gibt jetzt, also du konntest
nie im Hintergrund gucken, beispielsweise, ist auf einer Webseite jetzt irgendwie was
Neues verfügbar, dann download mir das oder sowas. Es wäre auf jeden Fall zu begrüßen
wenn das Apple ändert. Ja aber bei Android kannst du das abschalten mit dem Hintergrundprozess
killen. Bei iOS nicht. Haben sie zumindest in der Keynote gesagt? Ja. Ich fänd das gut,
ich fänd das wirklich gut. Ich fänd es schön, wenn das Opt-in ist, dass man standardmäßig
für den normalen Benutzer ist es ja auch vollkommen okay, dass der ein bisschen geschützt
wird durch amok laufende Apps. Das hat's unter Android früher öfters mal. Unter iOS geht
das halt nicht in der Art und Weise, dass der normale Anwender davon geschützt wird,
finde ich gut, wo es halt wirklich ätzend ist, ist wenn du dir darüber bewusst bist
und du bist dir auch bewusst, dass du es ausschalten willst, aber du darfst nicht, weil Apple
sagt ne, das geht nicht. Deswegen bin ich immer noch der Meinung, dass ähm, äh, ähm,
es ist eigentlich so, so blöd naheliegend irgendwie, aber ich find's trotzdem lustig.
Ähm, ja und du hattest halt unter iOS das Problem, selbst wenn du der Sache bewusst
warst und du wolltest das, dann ging's nicht. Es gibt, Apple hat eh ganz merkwürdige Sachen
drin. Zum Beispiel ist es so, dass manche Sachen nur im Safari gehen, aber halt nur
wenn sie wirklich in der App, die Safari heißt, geöffnet werden. Also sprich, ähm,
ach moin guck mal, die Hexe ist auch am Start. Ähm, allerdings nicht, wenn du ne eigene
App mit Safari Webview oder wie es dort heißt, ne wie heißt Webkit ist das oder, mit dem
iOS Webview hast. Also sprich, es gibt Dinger, die funktionieren nur im Webview, wenn er
mit Safari geöffnet wird. Im Webview deine Anwendung funktionieren sie nicht. Zum Beispiel
die ganze WebRTC-Geschichte funktioniert nicht richtig in eigenen Apps. RIP alle, die sich
erst in Pi 3 geholt haben. Ey, ich hab mir vor zwei Wochen zwei neue Kids geholt, ne,
mit äh, mit Gehäusen in Pi 3, mit Kühlern, mit Netzteil. Aber ist nicht schlimm. Kann
ich trotzdem für das verwenden, was ich verwenden wollte. Aber wenn sie das, ähm, wenn sie
das bei Apple ein bisschen lockern, am besten so, dass es Opt-in ist, fände ich das wirklich
gut. Weil aktuell ist es so, dass man in puncto Heimautomatisierung zum Beispiel das iPad
vergessen kann, weil du auf dem iPad eben nix automatisieren kannst, weil alles durch
User-Aktion angestoßen werden muss. Und beim Thema Heimautomatisierung geht es ja genau
umgedreht. Nicht, dass du was anstößt, sondern, dass die Heimautomatisierung für dich was
anstößt. Zum Beispiel ist es gar nicht so einfach, ähm, also fang mal an, was auf
Android total einfach ist. Zum Beispiel, wenn es an der Haustür klingelt, lass dann
auf dem Android Tablet, sagen wir mal, VLC geöffnet wird und der Livestream von der Kamera
am Tor sich startet. Das ist unter Android. Da kannst du mit Tasker machen, kannst du
mit Thermos, mit allem eigentlich. Das ist unter Android. Moment, ich sag's euch gleich,
was es unter Android ist. Ja, das hier ist es unter Android. Ist das unter, ist das unter
Android. Unter iOS geht das nicht. Das höchste der Gefühle, was du bisher unter iOS machen
konntest, ist, du kannst eine Push-Notification schicken, wo dann ein passend formatierter
Link drinne ist, den der User anklicken muss und dann, ähm, gibt's ein Callback zum VLC,
der VLC öffnet sich, der VLC kriegt über diesen Callback eine Uhr zur Kamera überliefert,
aber das muss alles per Userinteraktion gestartet werden. So ist das bei Apple. Das heißt,
so eine einfache Sache wie, es klingelt an der Tür und, äh, App mit Kamerastream geht
auf, ist unter iOS aktuell nicht möglich. Geht nicht. Könnt ihr euch noch so sehr verbiegen,
es geht nicht. Es sei denn, du würdest dir wahrscheinlich eine komplett eigene App programmieren
dafür, zertifizieren lassen von Apple und den App Store bringen. Die genau darauf zugeschnitten
ist, aber okay, wer, wer macht sowas, weil, es müsste dann mehr oder weniger genau für
mich programmiert sein. Unter Android ist es easy, dann nimmst du einfach Tasker oder
irgendwas anderes in der Richtung, machst du, machst du drei Einträge und es funktioniert.
Einfach Jailbreaken, ja. Aber das ist natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit. Ich weiß gar nicht,
gibt es überhaupt einen Jailbreak fürs aktuelle iOS? Die haben sich doch auch ziemlich schwer
getan in letzter Zeit, überhaupt noch was zu finden. Guck mal, gib mal ein Lager an.
Benutzst du eigentlich sowas wie KDE Connect? Äh, äh, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Welche, oh, das ist eine interessante Frage. Welche MikroTik würdest du mir empfehlen
nach meinem Telekom-Router, aber weder über MikroTik CK8-Geräte und G5-Lan-Geräte? G5?
Was, G5? Du meinst 5 Gigabit-Lan-Geräte, oder? G5 ist jetzt neues Mobilfunk, das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht. Willst du, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, willst du WLAN über MikroTik
machen, oder hast du schon einen Access Point und willst den nur an MikroTik anschließen?
G5-Geräte, die haben jetzt was Neues, das ist richtig cool. Der dürfte wahrscheinlich
für dich ziemlich gut sein. Und zwar, äh, der da oder der da? Da hast du noch ein bisschen
Platz für oben. Bei dem hier, bei dem einen hast du 10 Anschlüsse, bei dem anderen hast
du, also die sind relativ neu, der hier ist glaube ich relativ neu, ähm, der hat noch
ein SFP-Plus-Port. Achso, Moment, wenn du den Telekom-Router ausmachen willst, ne, ne,
ne, ne, das funktioniert nicht so einfach. Ähm, also als DSL-Modern eignen sich die
Dinger, eignen sich die Dinger nicht, sondern nicht gut. Das sind wirklich eher Router,
weniger Multifunktionsgeräte, wie eine Fritzbox. Also da musst du dir überlegen, wie du das
mit der Einwahl machst. Also, ehrlich gesagt, mich würd nicht wundern, wenn die Dinger
auch nicht PPOE können, können sie wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, hab ich damit noch nie gemacht,
aber du brauchst auf jeden Fall ein Modem, weil ein DSL-Modem ist nicht drin. Ach, das
soll der Telekom-Router machen? Ja, dann, ja doch, dann sowas hier. Also ich hab den
hier, im Prinzip, du kannst auch erst mal klein anfangen, du kannst auch erst mal sowas
hier nehmen, ähm, den hab ich gerade, bloß bei mir ist es so, der Router routet wirklich
nur. Bei mir ist da noch ein 10G-Switch dahinter. Jetzt ist es ein bisschen blöd, weil der hat
nur Gigabit, aber die interne Sache ist halt alles am 10Gigabit-Switch dran und von dort
gehts halt dann an den Router dran. Der hat halt keinen WLAN, der hat keinen WLAN, dafür
ist der relativ günstig. Die Dinger sind recht teuer, die kosten so 200, 300 Euro oder
so, ähm, der hier ist halt günstig, der kostet 45, also falls du schon einen Access-Point
hast. Ansonsten kannst du dir einfach den nächst höheren holen, oder aber, und das
ist ne Sache, die man, die man, wenns günstig sein soll, tatsächlich empfehlen kann, du
holst hier ein Hex-PoE und du machst, ähm, an den PoE-Port machst du den kleinsten Mikrotink-Access-Point
dran, den sie nämlich haben, nämlich den, äh, ach hier, äh, den da, oder den da. Das
ist allerdings, ähm, nicht wirklich zeitgemäß mehr, muss man sagen, das ist plus 2,4 GHz
G-Laden. Wenns was integriertes sein soll, dann, wie gesagt, sind die hier nicht verkehrt.
Oder gar der da, der hat noch ein bisschen mehr, aber der dürfte eher zu deinem Profil
passen, ja. Was ist das, das sind Router, ne Router, wie die coolen Leute sagen. Auf
welchen Subreddits treibst du dich rum? Boah, auf so vielen, äh, ohne Scheiß, es ist wirklich
so viel, dass mir jetzt kaum spezifische Sachen, da muss ich in mein Handy gucken, ja. PC-Master-Race
bin ich oft, äh, Self-Hosted, Unix-Porn, Unix-Porn ist ein cooles Subreddit, hat überhaupt
nix damit zu tun, wie es sich anhört. Home-Server, Self-Hosted, Home-Automation, ja, mehr sieht
man jetzt leider nicht. Ich, ich, ich kann mir das irgendwie gar nicht richtig merken,
ich denke immer an ein gewisses Thema und dann sag ich, aha, lass mal auf Reddit gucken.
Was, was, letzte Preis, ist auch lustig. Ich bin auf ganz vielen Subreddits. Ich schreib
aber auf Reddit nix, ich lese eigentlich nur. Data-Horder, ja, da bin ich auch öfters.
Aber den kannst du dir mal angucken, ja, als, als, als Router, Bobble Gaming. Ich glaub,
das müsste eigentlich für dich ganz gut passen und du bist ganz gut, äh, gewappnet, wenn
du nämlich sagst, hey, ich möchte bei mir mal 10 Gigabit aufrüsten, daheim hast du
schon Uplink-Port. Das ist natürlich sehr praktisch. He, he, das, ich bin immer, wie
viele Leute sind überhaupt mitkriegen das hier Random Chars? Ja, ja, das ist, das mach
ich manchmal. Ja. Bring's nice, wie viele Leute dazu kommen.
So, ähm, jetzt hab ich fast alle Fragen im Chat durch. Da kommen wir mal zu zwei Sachen,
die ich mir aufgeschrieben hab, falls die Leute noch da sind, mal schauen. Ähm, mich
hat vorhin einer gefragt, zum, meine Meinung zum Reboot von Modern Warfare. Neue Engine,
neue Engine, ist derjenige noch da, der es gefragt hat? Zumindest hat er gefragt, Meinung
zum Reboot von Modern Warfare. Neue Engine, kontroverse Story, ähnlich wie die No-Russians-Mission.
Also ich muss sagen, das könnte mal wieder ein Kot sein, das ich mir seit Black Ops
kaufen würde. Ähm, neue Engine, neue Engine, ähm, mal gucken, die basteln ja immer dran
rum. Das, was ich bisher gesehen hab, sah tatsächlich ganz nice aus, vor allem auch
weil ich das Modern Warfare Setting eigentlich ganz gern hab. Also ich fand Black Ops cool
vom Setting her, die Zukunftsgeschichten halt gar nicht und zu viel Zweiter Weltkrieg auch
nicht. Also ich finde, das Modern Warfare Setting war sowohl in Battlefield als auch
in Call of Duty das, was die Serie eigentlich am besten gemacht hat. Erzähl das in einem
Video. Ja, kann ich vielleicht machen. Ähm, eine kontroverse Story, ganz ehrlich, brauchst
bei mir nicht. Vor allem nicht, wenn die an den Hahn herbeigezogen kontrovers ist. Das
Coole an der Story in CoD 4 war ja, dass man mit manchen Sachen damals noch gar nicht gerechnet
hat. Ja, ich mein, wer hätte damit gerechnet, dass man, dass das wirklich dir, dass da wirklich
in der Stadt die Atombombe hochgeht in CoD 4. Da hätte keiner mit gerechnet und dementsprechend
war man damals auch geschockt, vor allem weil der Hauptcharakter dann auch, weiß nicht,
stirbt bei der Flucht da. Ähm, das hat man so auch noch nicht gesehen. Mittlerweile
haben die das jetzt aber schon so oft durchgezogen, dass man sich sagt, ok, da müssen sich was
Neues, Neues einfallen lassen. Äh, Ubuntu bietet jetzt doch zwei, drei Spitzleibirgs an. Na, Gott sei Dank, äh, Spoiler!
Alter, das Game ist von wann? 2007? Willst du mal wieder Battlefield 3 Rushstream machen?
Ey, wenn das noch jemand spielt, warum nicht? Ja...
Da hat mir vorhin noch einer einen Comment geschrieben, gehackte Switch mit Nvidia Streaming.
Wundert mich nicht, dass es das Ganze jetzt gibt, weil im Kern ist ja im Shield TV und
im Shield Tablet und so ist ja alle diese, ist ja überall diese Tegra T1, T1-Geschichte
drinnen und in der Switch auch. Deswegen wundert mich das nicht, dass das prinzipiell möglich ist.
Auf der Vita, ja, das habe ich gelesen. Das, äh, Vita-Flashen, aber das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben,
das wäre was, was wir im Stream machen könnten, oder? PS Vita-Flashen. Darf man das? Oder ist das
Monkathos? Das ist wahrscheinlich Monkathos, oder? Vita-Flashen auf Twitch.
Ich hab ne Vita, ich hab ne Release Vita, ja. Wieso sollte das Monkathos sein? Die Frage ist
eigentlich eher, warum sollte das nicht Monkathos sein? Naja, man darf das schon, man darf das,
weil es eine eigene Konsole ist. Die Frage ist nur, ob der Hersteller das so geil findet und ob das
dementsprechend Twitch so geil findet. Ich kann beispielsweise auf YouTube auch irgendwelche
Hacking-Geschichten hochladen, allerdings kann es durchaus sein, dass die YouTube löscht.
Also, ob du das privat darfst, ist was ganz was anderes, als ob du das auf der Plattform darfst.
Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist Monkathos. Warum ist das Monkathos? Das ist Monkathos,
richtig. Wieso geht Monkathos nicht? Weil ich alle meine, bei der Twitch-TV-Emotes schon voll hab
mit anderen Emotes, da ist Monkathos nicht drinne. Hat Sony die PS Vita nicht eingestellt? Naja,
wenn es TOS-Sachen gibt, wie das betrifft. Okay, Twitch, can I hack? Fragen wir erstmal.
In games, das geht ja schon in eine, could I stream hack-programming? Das ist doch schon mal
was in der Richtung. Da könnte man PS Vita-Flashen ganz klar dazuzählen, auch wenn es nicht
Hacking im eigentlichen Sinn ist, aber das kann man mit Sicherheit so auslegen.
Against access to and sometimes tamper with information in a computer system könnte man
auch Vita-Flashen dazuzählen. Also, das ist gar nicht so klar, als dass man, darf man
ja nicht so schnell, wie man es kann. Also, ich könnte mir vorstellen, das ist wirklich
Monkathos. Ja, wenn ich Partner wäre, könnte ich tatsächlich mal den Support fragen, aber
ich glaube, das ist so ein Thema, wenn du den Support fragst, die werden auf Nummer sicher
gehen und sagen, lieber nicht. Lad mal Hacking-Geschichten auf Videos hoch. Du meinst die krassen
Hacking-Geschichten, wo die ganzen Grills weggebankt werden, weil, so wie das gewisse
andere Leute auf YouTube gemacht haben vor ein paar Jahren. So 12 am Stück, bam, bam.
So ein spezieller auf YouTube fällt mir da so ein, der so Videos in der Richtung gemacht
hat. Hau die Frage einfach in den Twitch-Subreddit ein. Äh, dann muss ich mich auf Reddit anmelden.
Gibt's den eigentlich auf YouTube noch? Die krassen Banger. Macht der, lädt der noch
Videos hoch? Ne, macht er nicht. Vor zwei Jahren. Vor zwei Jahren. Und hier? Der ist
ja noch aktiver als ich auf YouTube. Ich muss ja sagen, ähm, wer mich vor ein paar
Jahren auf der Gamescom echt überrascht hat, so aus diesem Dunstkreis, ja, war tatsächlich
MontanaBlack. Das war ein echt, damals zumindest, ein wirklich angenehmer Zeitgenosse, ja.
Wir haben ja nicht großartig viel miteinander geschwätzt, ein bisschen blablabla halt,
aber da war ich echt überrascht von uns. Hätte ich, so hätte ich den nicht eingeschätzt
vor den Videos her damals. Das war wirklich ein sehr netter Zeitgenosse da, vor ein paar
Jahren noch. Weiß ich, wie das jetzt ist. Ich hab ja, ich hab ja, man hört ja Dinger
hier, aber auf was man so hört, darf man ja hier auch meistens wenig geben. Wissen die
alle, wie du EL aussiehst? Ja, die meisten zumindest. Haha, wir übrigens auch. Ähm,
also ich hab zwar nie ein Video hochgeladen, wo ich vor der Kamera rumgesprungen bin, aber
es gibt Videos auf YouTube, wo man mich sieht, ja. Das heißt, wer aufgepasst hat, der weiß
das. Gibt zum Beispiel ein Video von, von irgendeinem Battlefield Event von vor ein paar
Jahren. Da steh ich so in der Ecke und guck blöd. Nein, nein, nein, nicht Max Reflection
Videos. Richtiges Video, wo ich drin rumsteh. Das hat bloß, hat bloß wahrscheinlich keiner
gecheckt, dass ich das bin. Woher auch, ja. Obwohl das damals eigentlich schon relativ
offensichtlich war. Mit nem Bier in der Hand, ja. Ja, das war, ich bin ja eigentlich überhaupt
kein Biertrinker normalerweise. Aber an irgendwas musst du dich da festhalten, wenn du auf einmal
unter so vielen Leuten bist, die du nicht kennst. Sauce, please, ja, das musst du ja
schon selbst finden. Also ein paar Leute, muss ich sagen, waren in echt, die ich bisher
kennengelernt hab, da hast du, wie gesagt, so von YouTube Streaming, sonst was, Geschichten,
waren in echt, echte Spaßten. Und ein paar, von denen ich gedacht hab, dass sie eigentlich
steppen sind, waren keine, aber gut, bei manchen ist es auch einfach so, wie ich es gedacht
hab, auch gewesen. Gartenvideos. Genau, das hier Baro, der macht's richtig, der ist wenigstens
Mod mit Leib und Seele. Also, der Krieger, den kenn ich ja auch nur von ein paar Jahren
von der Gamescom, da hat er genau so einen Eindruck gemacht, wie ich zu einigen aus Videos
erwartet hab. Also der ist nullverstellt. Und ein paar Leute waren einfach nur irgendwie
komisch. Wisst ihr, es gibt so Leute, die sind so komisch, da weißt du überhaupt nicht,
was so Sache ist bei denen. Jetzt nicht so cringe-mäßig, sondern du denkst einfach so,
Alter, was willst du, ja? Da waren viele dabei. Zu dieser Kategorie würde ich eigentlich
so die überwiegenden Leute zählen, die man so kennengelernt hat. Wie gesagt, ich war
ja nie auf sonnig vielen Sachen, ich hab mich ja vor so Real-Life-Geschichten, hab ich mich
immer gedrückt, da bin ich nur auf die Sachen gegangen, wo ich wirklich Bock drauf hat.
Also das uselessste Event war tatsächlich das Battlefield 1 Event. Das war auch das
letzte von dieser Art, wo ich hingegangen bin. Das war so unglaublich sinnlos. Da haben
wir uns nämlich, ich glaub das hab ich schon mal erzählt, aber das hat mich wirklich enttäuscht,
dass wir so ein Riesentamm-Tamm damals drum herum gemacht haben. Dann haben sie ja vorher
erzählt, hier in Berlin ein großer Battlefield-Reveal und ihr seht dort auch viel mehr, als es im
offiziellen Stream zu sehen gibt und ihr bekommt dann auch direkt alles an Material, kriegt
ihr einen USB-Stick danach, da könnt ihr dann direkt danach Videos aufnehmen zusammen und
wie ihr wollt und ihr habt dann quasi richtig viel zu sagen und viel Material und alles
könnt ihr erzählen. Also wir haben riesen Wind vor dem Event gemacht und dann waren
wir dann da und im Prinzip ist nichts von dem eingetreten, was sie großartig erzählt
haben. Der damalige Battlefield der Deutschland, Battlefield Community Manager war auch irgendwie
sehr merkwürdig. Der hat dann so Dinge losgelassen, wie wir fahren jetzt los, auch wenn noch nicht
alle im Bus sind und so komische Dinge und ich hab mir auch gedacht, die soll man nicht
auf den Sack gehen. Das war auch jemand, der wusste nicht so genau, woran du bist. Und
das Event an sich war wirklich übertrieben sinnlos. Wir haben danach, wir haben ja noch
nicht mal einen Stick gekriegt und es hat auch, es hat auch, haha, das Video, lol. Hahahaha.
Moment bevor ich weiter erzähle, ich muss das Video zeigen. Vor allem mit der Musik
dazu. Hahahaha. Da bin ich auf einer Tüte. Hahaha. Die Musik, alter. Hahahaha. So geil.
Hahahaha. Ey, das könnte man als Twitch-Emote nehmen, oder? Das ist so, das ist wie so,
wie so Forsen-Face da. Der hat doch auch so total verschobene Gesichter drinnen. Da muss
mir einer die Mode draus machen. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Hahahaha. Mal gucken, wie das als
Emote wirken würde. Gar nicht so schlecht, oder? Das würde gar nicht so schlecht, das
würde gar nicht so schlecht funktionieren als Emote. Wartet mal. Haha. Drücken, Paint,
wir waren das ja ganz, high quality Paint. Achso, warte mal. In Paint kann man nicht,
in Paint kann man nicht richtig skalieren, ne? Hahaha. Äh, jaja. Ich wein. Das würde
als Emote doch irgendwie ganz gut durchgehen, oder? Er müsste es natürlich noch ein bisschen
aufbereiten, oder so. Hahaha. Das ist so genial, ey. Krasser Scheiße. Muss mir das
mal speichern, dass ich das nicht vergesse. Da kann man echt irgendein Emote draus machen.
Oh man. Hahaha. Ja, um die Sache mit den Battlefield-Events mal abzuschließen. Im Endeffekt haben
wir dann da gesessen. Wir haben das gleiche gesehen, wie der Livestream gesehen hat. Wir
haben kein Material bekommen, wir waren viel später im Hotel und dass wir was machen konnten
als angekündigt wurde. Es gab kein USB-Stick, also wir hatten auch nicht mehr. Und das einzige,
was wir mehr zu sehen bekommen haben von dem ganz vielen super tollen Content und Exklusiv
waren 15 Sekunden oder 20 Sekunden extra Trailer, wo man gesehen hat, dass ein Flugzeug abstürzt.
Also für 20 Sekunden sind wir quasi zu diesem Event hingefahren und im Endeffekt hatte
man nur Nachteile durch das Event, weil jeder, der daheim gesessen hat, den offiziellen Livestream
angeguckt hat, sich dabei eine Sache notiert hat, vielleicht die ein oder andere Sachen
geklippt hat und danach ein Video gemacht hat, war 3 Stunden, 4 Stunden vor unseren Videos
online. Das war so ein unsinniges Event. Seitdem bin ich auf keins mehr hin in dieser
Richtung. Das war zu dumm. Ja und ehrlich, ich war zwar damals, ich hab mich damals zu
sehr von den Sachen drum herum hypen lassen. Eigentlich hab ich damals, als ich den Trailer
gesehen hab, so im Nachhinein denke ich mir so, eigentlich hast du jetzt da schon gedacht,
dass das Spiel zacken wird. Ich war damals noch voll begeistert. Da hab ich hier mit
dem, mit dem Lost und dem, äh, das da, mit dem Lost und dem Finn haben wir hier was aufgenommen
damals noch. Ich glaub der Lost war auch dabei. Ne anscheinend nur der Meshed. So und das haben
wir hochgeladen um, steht leider keine Uhrzeit mehr bei. Es war relativ spät schon. Egal,
ich blödes täuscht das. Und am Ende war das Spiel scheiße. Tja. Also von den Marketingleuten
muss ich sagen, wer war mir denn da halbwegs sympathisch von. Also wenn ich, wer auch so
einer war, wo ich nicht genau wusste an woran man war, ist der Xbox-Deutschland-Typ von
damals. Ich weiß nicht, ob er das jetzt noch ist. Ähm. Die Elgato-Leute haben wenigstens
immer gesagt, was Sache ist. Das fand ich gut. Mit denen ist man gut ausgekommen. Äh,
Call of Duty, auch wenn ich bisschen geflamed hab, ähm, mit dem Community-Manager hatte
ich überhaupt keine Probleme. Das erste Gespräch mit ihm war auch lustig. Hat er gemeint,
er würde mich ja gerne einladen, aber das geht nicht, weil ich so ein Flame-Video hochgeladen
hab. Überleg mal, wenn du so schon eröffnest, ey. Aber ich hab gesagt, ja okay, aber ich
lösche das Video jetzt nicht, ne, dann ladet mich halt nicht ein. Aber danach, ähm, kam
mit dem auch wirklich gut aus. Ähm, aber ansonsten waren die ganzen Marketingleute
im Prinzip genau das. Im Prinzip Marketing, viel heiße Luft, äh, ohne was dahinter und
auch auf die meisten, ohne dass man sich irgendwie drauf verlassen konnte. Und manche waren
auch ganz merkwürdige, merkwürdige. Wer auch noch ganz cool war, der es leider nicht
mehr ist, war der damalige, ähm, ich weiß nicht, was der war, äh, Community-Dude von,
von, ähm, Rocket? War das? Oder Razor? Rocket war das, glaub ich. War das Rocket mit dieser
komischen Joystick-Maus? Ja, ich glaub, das war Rocket. Ähm, nee, Rocket war das mit
der 3D-Talker-Maus, genau. Und dem Sofa, was dann so nie rausgekommen ist. Der war auch,
der war cool, mit dem hab ich mich eigentlich am, wir haben uns nicht oft gesehen, aber
mit dem hab ich mich verhältnismäßig gut verstanden, weil der auch Heavy-Metal hört.
Das war, da hast du so, da hast du so was, wo du mal dich zumindest mit den Leuten irgendwie
identifizieren kannst. Das fand ich lustig, der sah auch schon so aus, mit Bart und Hahn
und so, ne? Ja, aber jetzt genug YouTube-Zeug, weil da ist ja grade nicht so viel zu holen
bei mir. Es hört sich jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen so an, als fand ich alles scheiße,
oder find ich, ist ja gar nicht so. Da waren auch schon viele, waren auch schon coole Sachen
da, und vor allem, viele Leute, die man so von YouTube da getroffen hat, das war schon
ganz cool. Vor allem fand ich immer lustig, wie alle überrascht geguckt haben, als sie
mich gesehen haben, und so, ah, das ist der Max, oder? Waren sie überrascht? Na gut,
wusste ja auch keiner vorher, ne? Aber ich hab im Prinzip eigentlich mit keinem aktuell
irgendwie großartig Kontakt. Mit dem Kaboom zuletzt mal irgendwie ein bisschen Nachrichten
geschrieben, wobei das an mir liegt, er hat mich ja schon mal gefragt, ob ich mal futtern
gehen wollen, ich hab mich bis jetzt irgendwie nicht gerührt, so, also er kann da überhaupt
nichts für. Mit dem Finn hab ich nicht mal viel zu tun, mit dem Lost hab ich eigentlich
nicht mal viel zu tun, mit den anderen, mit Finn, wer hat man da sonst noch irgendwie
ab und zu irgendwie den, ach keine Ahnung, ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, mit Solution
hab ich auch nichts mehr zu tun, mit, also mit keinem so, den ich da eigentlich, also
aktuell hab ich eigentlich da mit gar keinem irgendwie was zu tun. Ja, mit dem Kieler Junge
auch nicht, mit der Silvaner auch nicht, mit dem, ja doch mit dem Friseur, ok, aber der
Friseur ist mal außen vor, weil den kannte ich vorher schon, und das ist ja nicht YouTube,
irgendwie, den kenn ich ja nicht von YouTube oder so. Bist du eigentlich eher intro oder
extrovertiert? Das hängt an der Umgebung. Also ich sag generell, würde ich sagen eher
introvertiert, das liegt aber hauptsächlich daran, weil ich hab's jetzt schon öfters
in Streams gesagt, und irgendwie glaubt mir das keiner, ich mag Leute nicht, also ich
würd nicht so weit gehen und sagen, ich hasse alle Menschen oder so, aber ich mag Leute
eigentlich selten. Ist das nicht die Norm? Ich glaube bei vielen Leuten ist das nicht
so. Ihr Kinder auch, ja, Kinder mag ich auch nicht, aber vor allem Kinder in der Bahn,
ansonsten jucken mich Kinder nicht so. Ähm, ansonsten, wenn Leute dabei sind, die ich
kenn und mit denen ich mich gut verstehe, musste mich eigentlich bremsen, dass ich
mal irgendwie Luft hole beim Schwätzen. Ich glaube, das sieht man eigentlich auch ganz
gut in ein paar Videos, die ich mit anderen Leuten aufgenommen hab. Ich mein, ich mach
das ja meistens. Ach ja, und wer auch echt nett war, ist der, hab ich ganz vergessen,
warum hab ich an den gedacht, der ehemalige SK Shocks, der, ich weiß gar nicht, war welcher,
war welcher, Orga oder wo die jetzt sind. Der Call of Duty Shocks, ja, mit dem hab ich
auch gut verstanden. Das war auch ein echt netter Kerl. G2 Shocks, ja, ich weiß nicht,
woran was er jetzt gerade macht. Der war auch wirklich nett. Shocks, ne, ein Shocks. Genau,
aber nicht der CSGO Spieler. Ich kann kein Französisch. Ja, aber wie gesagt, das sieht
man auch in den Videos, die ich mit anderen Leuten aufnehme, das mach ich ja mit Leuten,
die ich kenn, in der Regel, und mit denen man gut schwätzen kann. Und da ist ja teilweise
so, dass du mich schon bremsen musst, dass ich da mal die Fresse halte. Also, aber ansonsten
würde ich sagen, doch hauptsächlich Introvertiert, weil ich einfach keine Leute mag. Außer natürlich
Twitch Chat. Twitch Chat ist ausgenommen, Twitch Chat Beste. Twitch Chat. Aber, stell's
dir doch mal wieder schön. Ja, mach ich ja gerade. Deswegen finde ich es auch richtig
blöd, dass beim aktuellen GameStone Quick wieder die Paywall vor dem Chat ist. Ich hab's
gestern schon auf Twitter geschrieben. Ich fand die letzten Jahre nicht mehr so doll
davon im Event. Entweder liegt es daran, dass man sich an die Games gewöhnt hat, oder einfach,
dass die unterhaltsamen Leute irgendwie nicht da sind. Außer dem Paywall vor dem Chat ist
lächerlich. Gibt doch einen deutschen Reset. Ja, es gibt auch bei TriHacks im Channel den
Pleb-Chat. Aber es geht ja darum, dass der offizielle Channel quasi gepaywallt ist. Das
finde ich ätzend, ja. Das ist auch eine Sache, die, also mich persönlich ist es immer, wenn
ich eine Paywall sehe, eher ein Grund dafür, bis auf ganz wenige Ausnahmefälle, den Service
nicht weiter zu benutzen, als mir eine Subscription zu kaufen. Wenn ich was subscribe, dann eigentlich
nicht, weil sie mich nerven mit irgendwas oder weil irgendwas eingeschränkt wird oder
Pop-Ups, dass ich jetzt subscriben soll, sondern ich subscribe oder donate eigentlich zu Dingern,
wo es mir irgendwie jetzt danach ist. Guckst du irgendwie regelmäßig auf Twitch? Oh ja,
viele, viele. Warte mal, ich kann das grad mal sagen. Ich mach aber hier grad mal meine,
äh, meine Liste. Wo sieht man denn die Leute, die online sind? Ah man, hier. Krabby. Guck
ich beispielsweise total oft. Dance Game gucke ich oft. Dance Game ist, Dance Gaming ist für
mich der beste Let's Player, den es gibt. Oder generell, so eines der unterhaltsamsten Leute.
Und außerdem sieht er mir irgendwie verdammt ähnlich. Sagt der Fabian auch immer, ey. Aber
ich hab noch ein bisschen mehr Haare. X2Z gucke ich ab und zu. Ich find das übelst lustig.
Allerdings nur die Overwatch Streams. Das ist, wenn man mal irgendwie einen total abdrehen sehen
will, ist das immer ganz unterhaltsam. Sieger gucke ich auch immer, wenn er da ist. Krabby
hatte ich schon. Ich scroll hier grad mal durch. Wen haben wir dann sonst noch? Manche, ab und zu
Warcraft Streams gibt es hier noch ein paar. Gut, die Leute, die jetzt on sind, die gucke ich
eigentlich relativ selten. Ich gucke viele, viele Speedrun Channels. Die ganzen Speedgaming
Channels 1 bis 7 oder so und Deutsch, wo es so quasi bisschen ältere Games drauf gibt, mit
Commentary dabei. Dann sehe ich grad, ich hab Miramizu abonniert. Gucke ich aber eigentlich
so gut wie nie. Den Mexican Runner gucke ich noch öfters mal. Wer ist denn sonst noch on hier
gerade? Ne, das war's. Wer sind grad nicht on, von denen ich abonniert hab? Ich gucke ziemlich
viel Twitch. Was ich quasi gar nicht schaue auf Twitch, sind deutsche Channels. Willst du das neue
Warcraft 3 spielen? Ja, werd ich, weil ich wollte schon ewig mal die Kampagne richtig durchspielen.
Ich gucke keine deutschen Channels auf Twitch. Doch, ab und zu gucke ich mal beim Lost rein.
Ab und zu mal, ganz selten. Warcraft 3 hat glaube ich vier Kampagnen. Du hast die Menschenkampagne,
die Ork Kampagne, die Nachtelf Kampagne. Ne, doch. Eine Undead Kampagne gab es nicht. Das
Addon ist quasi so ne Art Undead Kampagne gewesen. Mit dem Lich King. Wie sieht's mit dem neuen
Modern Warfare aus? Hier hab ich ja grad was zu erzählen. Mal gucken. Ja, ich finde auch,
sieht ganz gut aus. Weil ich ganz cool finde, dass sie da den Hauptdarsteller von Six drinne
haben. Hab mich schon gewundert, wo ich den Trailer gesehen hab. Habe ich gedacht, du hast
den doch gesehen. Das ist doch der eine Typ aus Six. Und das ist er auch. Da haben sie zumindest mal
einen, der mit dem Setting Erfahrung hat. Es hat auf jeden Fall das Potenzial, dass die Kampagne
richtig cool wird. Was ich übelst verwirrend finde, ist, dass es einfach nur Modern Warfare heißt.
Kennst du noch Chigaks HD? Ja, den kenn ich noch. Von dem hab ich auch schon eine Weile nichts mehr
gehört. Den Tylo mit OO kenn ich auch noch. Das ist ein anderer. Von dem hab ich auch schon
noch nichts mehr gehört. Erkennen tu ich die meisten ja noch, wenn ich was gemacht hab. Da hab ich
eigentlich mit dem Eax hab ich noch am meisten zu tun, wenn's auch wenn zu tun heißt ab und zu mal
eine Nachricht im Discord schreiben. Wie zufrieden bist du jetzt eigentlich nach einigen Monaten mit
deinem MikroTik-Router? Gut, top. Kennst du Daueratmer noch, der Gaming? Ja klar, den kenn ich auch noch.
Ich glaub, der hieß Aaron, oder? Nee, der Selfon hieß Timo. Ich glaub, das war er. Er kenn ich noch.
Suche selbst, das läuft nicht mehr, lief noch nie, ist noch nicht fertig.
Worauf ich mich viel mehr freue, ist, wenn es wirklich so weit sein sollte, dass tatsächlich
nächstes Jahr Bad Company 3 kommt. Wenn das angekündigt wird, dann flippe ich aus und
wahrscheinlich werde ich mir dann Gameplay angucken und feststellen, sie haben keine Ahnung,
wie ein ordentliches Bad Company aussehen muss. So wird's kommen, ich sag's euch. Sie kündigen
an Bad Company 3, richtig geiler Trailer mit einem richtig geilen Soundtrack dabei und dann
siehst du das erste Gameplay und stellst fest, Moment, das hat auch mit Bad Company überhaupt
nichts zu tun. Genauso stelle ich mir das vor. Es ist ja nicht von DICE, also nicht von den
Schweden, nicht Schweden DICE angeblich, sondern es ist von LA, das ist so Dings hier, die ist
nicht Danger Close früher gewesen, die modernen, die Metal of Honor Typen. BF3 war ja quasi BC3,
naja, also BF3 und Bad Company 2 haben sich ja schon mal komplett anders gespielt. Fängt ja
dann schon daran an, dass die bei dem anderen hinlegen kannst und bei dem anderen nicht. Auch die
Waffen und alles und die Maps, das hat sich komplett anders angefühlt. Schweden DICE kriegt nichts mehr
gebacken, siehst du ja. Battlefront 2 kacke, Battlefield 1 kacke, Battlefield 5 kacke. Was haben die
sonst noch so gemacht in letzter Zeit? Nichts, oder? Reicht ja auch. Bad Company 3 mit Auto Chats,
da warte ich noch drauf. Wenn das der nächste Hype wird, dann ist jetzt quasi Battle Royale
out und alle machen sie in den Auto Chats. Stream mal Witcher 3, das Game ist viel zu lang. Außerdem
habe ich schon komplett durchgespielt. Das Einzige, was ich noch nicht durchgespielt habe in
Witcher 3 ist das Addon, das erste Addon. Das zweite auch nicht richtig. Die Hexe, dann gehen wir löschen
oder rufen wir die Feuerwehr wenigstens. Löschen würde ich nicht gehen, das ist gefährlich,
aber rufen wenigstens die Feuerwehr. Was sagst du zu Cyberpunk 2077? Habe ich ganz am Anfang schon
gesagt, es ist überhaupt nicht mein Setting das Spiel, allerdings traue ich dem Hersteller viel zu
und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass es mir trotzdem Spaß macht, wenn ich es denn kaufen sollte,
obwohl mir das Setting nicht zusagt. Fallout Battle Royale, das hat mich letzten Stream echt
geschockt. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das gibt, bis ihr mir das erzählt habt und da war ich echt
geschockt, dass die die lassen nichts aus. Hast du meine Frage gesehen? Nee, habe ich nicht,
muss noch mal posten. Auto Chess ist doch Schach, nee. Auto Chess ist quasi sowas mit Dota Units
automatisch gegeneinander antreten lassen, wo es halt besonders auf die Positionierung und die
Kombination ankommt. Auto Chess gibt es auch für Leute, dass die sich das nicht nehmen lassen,
dachte ich mir.
Ach doch, jetzt habe ich doch die
Frage gesehen. Ich habe mal eine Frage, passt zwar nicht zum Thema, aber mein PC friert immer
regelmäßig, wenn ich zum Beispiel Witcher oder Overwatch spiele ein. Wie fixe ich das? Das kann
man aus der Entfernung schlecht sagen. Bei Belastungen einfrieren klingt immer so ein
bisschen nach Überhitzen. Kann aber auch genauso gut defekter RAM sein, defekter Grafikkarten RAM.
Also ich würde sagen Überhitzung und kaputter RAM sind so die Hauptdinger beim einfrieren.
Keine Ahnung. Das ist tatsächlich eine knifflige Frage. Friert ein PC ein, wenn es zu heiß wird?
Tja. Heute kriege ich ja viele Donations. Ich muss mal reingucken,
da ich nicht was übersehen habe. Oh, aus Versehen wieder eine Spende. Der ist schon wieder da. Nice,
Dankeschön. Ich muss mal tippistream gucken. Tippistream Dashboard. Oh, ich habe was übersehen vor
einer Stunde. Vor einer Stunde hat der Astflex gefragt, ob ich dieses Projekt
schon mal gesehen habe. Ich habe mir das Video gerade angeschaut. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Mal verklaut nur Mods. Ist zum Teil richtig. Wobei sie zumindest bei CS mit dafür
gesorgt haben, dass der Mod überhaupt möglich war. Okay Leute, es ist 21.45 Uhr. Ich muss morgen
wieder arbeiten gehen. Ich habe unglaublich Bock drauf. Aber wenn der Raspberry Pi morgen kommt,
und ich ausgehe, probieren wir das morgen mal aus, was das Ding so hergibt. Ich gucke gerade mal,
ob da eine Trackingnummer dabei ist oder so. Die Bestellung wurde versandt. Telekom. Schauen wir
mal. Ah, und noch irgendwas anderes ist on the way. Was habe ich denn da noch bestellt?
Könnt ihr euch noch an den vorletzten Stream erinnern mit dem Ultraschall-Sensor? Nee, das hat
keine Ahnung mehr was ich überhaupt erzähle. Da muss ich das auch nicht erzählen. Ja, ich
habe das öfters eine Benachrichtigung gekriegt, dass das irgendwas auf dem Weg ist. Ich habe keine
Ahnung mehr ab, was es ist. Zumindest diesen Ultraschall-Sensor, den wir im letzten Arduino
Programmier-Stream hatten, von dem gibt es eine neuere Version, und die neuere Version kann 3,3
Volt bis 5 Volt. Da habe ich mir einen 5er-Pack von bestellt und die wurden gerade verschickt. Das
heißt, das können wir dann fertig machen in einem der nächsten Streams. Arduino. Es ist nicht
original Arduino, es ist ESP32 Arduino-kompatibel. Poggers heißt jetzt übrigens Poggi und nicht mehr
Poggers. Warum weiß ich nicht. Habe ich nirgendwo was gefunden, warum Poggers jetzt Poggi heißt.
Wann pushst du das neue Meme-Board, wenn ich es irgendwann mal fertig habe? Oder zumindest so,
dass man es ordentlich benutzen kann. Man kommt mal wieder auf YouTube, wenn ich Bock auf YouTube
habe. Das ist so eine Sache, ja. Außerdem finde ich viele Teile vom Meme-Board übelst hässlich
gemacht. Jetzt müssten wir auch mal fertig machen. Ich müsste so viel Zeug eigentlich noch
fertig machen. Ich hoffe, ich kriege da im Dezember einiges gebacken. Oder vielleicht, ich hoffe,
das meiste im Dezember, wenn nicht sogar alles im Dezember gebacken. Weil im Dezember habe ich
wieder einen kompletten Dezember-Urlaub. Das heißt, sollte ich da wieder das so bescheuert machen wie
letztes Jahr, quasi groß erzählen, ich stream jetzt einen Monat lang und dann wieder nichts machen,
müsst ihr mir schön auf den Sack gehen auf Twitter. Weil ihr habt es ja mittlerweile mitgekriegt,
wenn ich erstmal anfange mit Streamen, dann geht das, ja. Aber wenn ich länger als eine
Woche Pause habe, dann mache ich nichts mehr. Das kennt das Solution bestimmt auch. So wie
ich den kenne, hat er genau das gleiche Problem. Wie mit Sport. Ey, ich habe sechs Kilo abgenommen.
Durch die beste Taktik überhaupt einfach weniger essen. Du darfst nicht mehr aufhören zu streamen.
Ich muss jetzt aber ins Bett. Zumindest eine halbe Stunde muss ich ins Bett. Wenn ich quasi
streme, bis ich dann direkt ins Bett gehe, dann kann ich erstmal nicht pennen.
Streben dich beim Schlafen, ja ist klar. Dann kann er noch langweiliger streben, ja.
3D Drucker streamen die Nacht durch. Das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Schmeiß doch die Katz vor die Cam, die bleibt da nicht sitzen, wenn ich die da hinsetze.
Das Tool kann man, naja, du kannst eine ganz, ganz, ganz alte Version auf meinem GitHub
Repo runterladen. Aber da ist vieles noch gar nicht drin von dem, was ich hier im Stream
mache. Das Tool kann er noch mehr. Das kann Overlay
machen und Text-to-Speech. Und sogar animierte GIFs und Katzenbilder.
Na gut, nee, nur weil ich die reingezogen habe. Wo habe ich eigentlich meine anderen
zwei Katzen hin, wo sind die denn? Da ist eine und die, was, Chico ist noch,
warum geht das auf? Warum habe ich Chico noch gar nicht hier als Bild drinne?
Das geht nicht, da müssen alle drei rein. Die hat mich im Blick, äh, der Schrank ist
schräg hinter mir hier. Da sitzt sie manchmal obendrauf und dann
feste ganz genau beobachtet er.
Die meisten Bilder, die ich drinne, verwende ich irgendwie überhaupt nicht.
Wann kommt der Raspberry Pi 4 raus, heute? Oh, die Katze ist vor der Tür, was ist da
los, Tür ist genau, wartet mal. Was? Traut sie sich nicht rein?
Na komm her, jetzt traut sie sich nicht rein. Hier ist warm drin, da willst du gar nicht
rein. Nein, jetzt will ich nicht rein, bloß dass
die Tür zu ist, das geht natürlich nicht. So, ich muss mich jetzt um meine Katze kümmern.
Wir sehen uns nächstes Mal, bis dann, machts gut, CU.